salut c'est tout moi ça va très très
bien stuff bien content d'être avec toi
aujourd'hui pour commenter c'est
championnats du monde de rapides c'est
vraiment super cool comme événement
c'est bien qu'on aime ça et du coup bah
ça va être plus que sympa avec un
Carlson très en forme des Français qui
sont bien présentés on espère que Maxime
va bien tourner aujourd'hui parce que ça
commence à devenir de plus en plus
important c'est ça donc hier on a eu
cinq parties et à l'issue de ces cinq
parties et ben on a mvl qui se situe
avec trois points et demi sur 5 on a
aussi deux autres Français on a
Sébastien Mazet et jus de Moussard qui
ont trois points sur cinq aussi qui font
un tournoi honorable et on va voir un
petit peu ce qui nous font aujourd'hui
voir ce qu'ils peuvent ce qu'ils peuvent
faire
pas tout à fait les mêmes objectifs pour
les deux disons que Jules peut prétendre
même je sais pas la victoire finale bon
je sais pas comment il situe mais en
tout cas il est quand même très très
dangereux très très en forme et
pour Sébastien m'a justement il a envie
de taper tous les plus gros mais ils ont
des objectifs légitimement assez
différents quand même il y a une marge
maintenant entre entre les deux joueurs
que l'on va dire que Jules en cadence
rapide il est vraiment très très
dangereux on peut battre à peu près tous
les jours présents et donc Julie peut
prétendre à je pense à un petit top 10
voir plus si vraiment il est en forme et
qui fait des choses bien alors que vous
savez que Sébastien il fait quand même
plus je pense qu'il veut il veut juste
s'amuser et faire un bon tournoi et pour
l'instant il fait un bon tournoi avec 3
sur 5 c'est déjà pas mal et donc Maxime
trois points et demi donc Maxime bon ben
il est champion du monde de Blitz donc
évidemment il vient je veux le temps là
pour gagner le tournoi pour gagner
l'événement donc voir un petit peu
comment Maxime s'en sort donc je vais
vous mettre si vous voulez un petit peu
les caméras parce que là on va commencer
à bientôt enfin les parties vont
commencer dans dans une minute donc je
vais vous mettre la vue normale alors je
vais regarder je suis pas sûr je pense
pas que Maxime et une caméra sur lui
vous savez que
Maxime là le tableau 10 et du coup j'ai
accès à 5 caméras normalement il y a une
caméra par table et
une caméra qui fait toute la salle
donc non et d'ailleurs caméra qui fait
la salle généralement après elle va
table 1
là où est Carlson
on va tout Acquier avec s'installe Douda
c'est quelle table stable 4 c'est bien
ça
donc j'ai pas de caméra sur sur mvl donc
faut qu'il remonte si il veut sa cam
hier on essayait hier on se battait pour
qu'il soit retransmis et puis on n'a pas
réussi encore mais il y a eu un départ
un peu difficile quand on se pardonnes
et donc covalet et contre tabac à bebe
de lâcher des plumes bah oui claire
monstrueux les mecs qui sont à 4 et demi
bon c'est très très fort quoi mais tu
vois juste ronde un c'est quand même
censé être forfaits
qui a quand même
200650 quoi
c'est quand même pas facile
on va aller si c'était signaler non
quand Magnus avait fait son record
d'invincibilité il me semble que il
était complètement foutu contre relève
il avait arraché le demi-point si je dis
pas de bêtises c'est possible mais bon
courage c'est c'est un joueur de Ligue 1
qui quasiment 2016
c'est tu as pour une première ronde
c'est pas c'est pas fric
joueur donc les règles c'était les
champions nationaux plus les plus de
2550 dans un des classement alors
minimum dans un des trois classes
classement sur les 12 dernières années
champion national et ensuite il y avait
10 je crois à peu près 10 invités feed
et 15 invités la Fédération il y a pas
de pigeon quoi c'est clair c'est de
toute façon faut aller passer ces
vacances de Noël au Kazakhstan les mecs
ils viennent pas pour rien quoi il y a
quelques mecs qui viennent se faire
plaisir mais ils sont rares déjà c'est
des mecs à plus de 25 50 donc ça c'est
oui les joueurs qui ont 2016 plus ils
viennent pour gagner quoi exactement et
les autres qui ont 2550 ils viennent
pour franchement
c'est c'est fort quoi comme toi tu as 40
quoi et bien sûr non mais j'y pensais
toi c'est marrant parce que mon premier
élo que j'ai eu en blitz parce que bon
bien sûr j'aurais jamais eu 25 50 ans en
l'an
ni rapide mais en blitz son premier élo
j'ai 24 99 il suffisait après de faire
deux bons tournois tu passes 25 50 il va
une fois pour le kiffe quoi voilà mais
maintenant c'est mort après j'ai pas
réussi à tenir ça dites c'est dur de
toute façon mais c'est vrai qu'on
rêverait de faire un tournoi comme ça
surtout en rapide hyper intéressant
c'est clair c'est c'est tellement
tellement fort quoi et c'est vraiment
sympa quand tu vois quand tape 87 on
voit que c'est un 24 50
bonjour des chats qui sont comment
perdition totale il en faut bien
quelques-uns dans ce genre de tournoi
ouais c'est ouf
salut à tous salut Siri c'est exerçonne
pietrogue bienvenue à tous ceux qui
viennent d'arriver sur le sur le chat
bienvenue pour cette deuxième journée de
championnat du monde
avec du coup mvl contre
qui est champion olympique avec son
équipe 12 bakistan
et ouais donc c'est un jeune ouzbek qui
ne cesse de progresser et on va voir du
coup un petit peu
ce qui se passe dans cette partie donc
du coup Maxime qui elle est blanche dans
cette partie
[Musique]
dommage dommage dommage non mais il y
avait les fêtes de Noël du coup il a dû
faire calme
[Musique]
il a fait fort et après après c'est un
petit peu calmé ou alors que c'est pas
encore couché
il rentre à la maison
c'est bon ça c'est comment vas-tu
comment vas-tu
[Musique]
on va bien
tous déjà salut gros dents d'ailleurs ça
dure dans
et réveille pas trop difficile il se
moque un peu mais j'ai un petit avantage
par rapport à ce stuff pour hier j'avais
une grosse soirée c'est tout enfin
soirée de Noël machin bon du coup j'ai
calmé le jeu mais quand même c'était
assez dur mais comme petit avantage chez
gagne une heure par rapport à ce tout
fin
donc du coup pour tout les 9h06 c'est ça
Stéphane c'est moi il est 9h du matin
ouais et demain d'ailleurs demain c'est
encore plus tôt
demain c'est non demain c'est une heure
plus tard il me semble moi je crois que
c'est une heure tu m'as dit ça tu sais
dans un message que c'était une heure
plus tard mais je crois que c'est une
heure plus tôt si je dis pas de bêtises
désolé de te la prendre dans ce cas là
je veux ça va être vraiment une grosse
désillusion pour toi mais je souhaite
avoir tort il me semble que tu as tort
mais j'espère
parce que là je regarde
et je vois en fait toujours pareil je
crois que
je sais pas si devenu que pour le bitson
allemand
ce qui peut gagner le rapide il le fera
il y a pas de souci là-dessus c'est
juste que c'est dur quoi comme on le
disait partout là tu vois il va jouer à
26 50 c'est il y a que des super joueurs
quoi que des Templiers quoi
10 heures c'est tout oui en cette
période c'est particulièrement tôt mais
bon ça le fait pour nous mais pour tout
c'est c'est extrêmement dur quoi il a
vraiment du mérite vraiment du mérite il
me faut pas hésiter à le remercier dans
le chat alors oui donc là je regarde les
les je regarde les programmes et on a
tous les jours 10 heures sur le dernier
jour des rapides
pardon ce sera 9 heures
je peux vous le montrer
sur twitch et sur ça ça commence à la
partie regarde rapidement sur sur twitch
hop ça arrive on a 10 heures 10 heures
10 heures en rapide et le Blitz c'est
Deezer 9h je donnerai quelques
confirmation
[Musique]
au staff mais normalement c'est c'est ça
on sera bien à 9h le dernier jour sauf
c'est ça allez je vais lancer des
caméras je remets la notre
en part pour une petite espagnole
donc j'ai pas la caméra sur Maxime
malheureusement comme vous le savez bien
Maxime stable 10 mais on espère revenir
quand même je pense que si gagne
celle-là est quand même moins que le
tableau 10 tu vois
il est quand même il peut il peut
vraiment il peut vraiment revenir en
fait il a jamais il est jamais
véritablement parti
je pense que c'est parti Maxime il y a
trois moyens que que après il soit il
soit sur une caméra en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on espère
qui nous disait que Carsen allait
peut-être faire un Blackmar
avant de Forest avec les Blancs pour
cette deuxième journée de rapide mais
j'ai pas vu mais je pense pas je pense
pas donc on ira vérifier tout à l'heure
si cette news donnait undertale était
pertinente ou non
[Musique]
ok donc là on a une des Espagnols
standard espagnol
avec avec un petit Détroit
au final ce genre de position ça
ressemble énormément à l'italienne mais
on a provoqué à 6 B5 racis B5 c'est bien
stouffe pour pour les Noirs ils ont pris
de l'espace et puis mettre le fond en B7
mais on a souvent A4 qui déstabilise un
peu
cette aile dame et les pions deviennent
un petit peu faibles généralement
c'est pour ça que tu as fait trois
il va mettre le cahier en dessin qu'un
jour
où j'ai 5 et des 5 et des cinq fou G5 ça
c'est logique améliorer les pièces
comment vous savez pas quoi faire on
améliore les pièces c'est vraiment le
conseil qu'on donne de base
donc là les deux joueurs ses vertus
c'est bien pour tout le monde selon de
partir moi c'est le principe principe
principal
alors on peut se poser la question
ici
comment ça à regarder des cavaliers
prend E5 comme thématique aussi est-ce
qu'on a le droit de faire quand même
depuis le fou il est arrivé en C5
il y a ce motif là
c'est pas si facile
[Musique]
faut faire gaffe parce que imaginons on
fait ça on s'envole avec ce genre de
thématique qui allait prendre le 5 et 4
faudra faire attention parce que notre
four B3 il est un petit peu enfermé donc
un des motifs clés d'ailleurs c'est fou
prendre les cas d'apprendre des cartes
et quand on peut faire ces 5 c'est
génial là je peux pas pour l'instant il
faudra
menacer et la dame sera au centre et du
coup sans doute pour ça qu'on peut pas y
aller
Maxime qui réfléchit donc là il y a
plein de cours intéressants
c'est logique pour empêcher fouger 5
et puis
OK et pour ceux qui se demandent
pourquoi fouger 5 direct n'a pas été
joué il y avait peut-être cavaliers à
Saintes en fait
mais ça
gênait énormément le fou B3 et fou des 5
as et ses 6 donc c'était pas le principe
systématique dans ces positions pour
pour le clouage d'ailleurs je connais
cette position sans le rock tu vois il y
a une idée comme ça je sais pas si tu
connais avec un cavalier F6 il faut F6
fu D5 suivi de dans cette position
tourne G4 je sais pas si tu connais
autrement inconnu non mais je
m'attendais à quelque chose de plus
standard non ici non non pas s'expert
toute cette position enfin le thème
et puis après on va presser mais en fait
l'idée c'est de faire
et
après tu bouffes des 5 et après tu joues
ton géant et G4 et c'est très très fort
en fait
ceux qui nous rejoignent ouais moi je
pensais plutôt un truc standard tu
restes avec A4 tu vois je me prends pas
la tête je joue du
peut-être un peu trop simple en même
temps bon c'est le c'est le grand thème
qu'on connaît
c'est cool à jouer pour les blancs très
agréable
sur le pion B5 sortez pièce et puis
Maxime une potion de Jack qui est assez
confortable avec les Blancs donc on va
un petit peu comment comment il s'en
sort
un petit tour chez les français bien sûr
voir un petit peu ce que nous font
tiens cela s'est maser qui a les blancs
ici dans cette partie qui est une
quarantaine du coup
c'est classique pour l'instant voilà qui
est C4 prise cavalier C3 prise ou trois
bon pour l'instant c'est thématique de
mettre tous les pions en tension au
centre pour prendre l'initiative en fait
avec l'avance de développement du coup
là c'est hyper intéressant très
prometteur cette position pour pour les
blancs
j'aime beaucoup on voit un peu l'avance
développement quand même côté des blancs
les dents en plus de mal à sortir des
pièces et recontard alors que Sébastien
peut roquet en un coup et du coup
l'ouverture du centre va lui profiter
c'est certain et les dessins possibles
il faut prendre ces quatre avant aussi
c'est plutôt plutôt intéressant
il est où
[Musique]
je la connais je crois
c'est une sorte de ragonie exactement
H5 donc le fou qui a un problème en fait
ici en G3 et tu vois un truc du genre H3
ou F3 va y avoir qu'elle va les prendre
c'est peut-être pas si grave en fait
d'autant plus que même si un jour je
dois jouer F4 bah c'est pas trop grave
non plus c'est à dire bon c'est quand
même les mais je préfère jouer sans F4
François bien d'accord parce que j'ai
pas envie de trop aimé cases mes rois F2
c'est stable et j'ai ce que je vais
montrer c'est que j'ai le fou blanc
un grand F2 fou Detroit cavaliers 2
tac même si c'est peu conventionnel le
roi en F2 ben je suis hyper content quoi
c'est à dire que j'ai quand même les
bonnes pièces
et mon roi il est protégé c'est
comprendre que le roi il essaye il est
pas trop ta cave le cabane on avait
parlé de la cabane l'an dernier je crois
bah c'est à peu près ça c'est une cabane
voilà la cabane de Souley disons qu'il a
envoyé pietrogue mais le truc c'est que
il n'a pas non plus beaucoup de
beaucoup de pièces pour intervenir
maintenant tu vois il a envoyé un petit
peu les pions en avant mais il y a pas
de pièces en soutien d'un ds6.f2 je
pense pas qu'ils soient mieux les 20
jours F2 ici un peu forcé
de manière atypique alors cavalier C6
oui et non c'est à dire que ailleurs il
y a le schéma cavalier cette F5 on
attaque et le schéma plus positionnel
cavalier A5 pour faire un blocus du pion
C36 qui avait la 5 taper sur un casque
un tempo mais ce que j'ai le temps en
tout cas structurellement parlant vous
comprenez je pense pourquoi jusqu'où là
pour échanger pion de lait concluant du
centre
développer mes pièces et surtout pas me
faire fixer mon pion avec Cavalia 5
maintenant faut regarder si j'ai eu la
tête prévue cavalier 7 cavalier 5 avec
en pratique des petites menaces surtout
en rapide vous voyez qu'il a 14 minutes
qu'on trouve 11 minutes mais déjà
beaucoup de pression René cet aspect si
tout n'est pas parfait vous devez au
moins mettre la pression sur
l'adversaire en match rapide c'est
encore plus payant quand
qu'en partie lente l'adversaire a moins
de temps de se défendre sous pression
voilà non c'est 4 c'est pas mal parce
que tu vois au final après des profs ou
prends ces quatre bah les noirs n'ont
pas de pions au centre au final tu vois
quand même deux pions pour les blancs
contre 0 pions pour les Noirs après il
faut voir si on a le temps de faire ça
vu qu'il faut quand même le roi en deux
on n'est pas encore bien développé de ce
côté là c'est pas si sûr mais en tout
cas ça a l'air intéressant et puis comme
là aussi souligné Kévin c'est vrai que
les Noirs ont comme idée de venir mettre
un cavalier pour éventuellement bloquer
la pousser ses quatre
c'est peut-être le seul moment en fait
pour le faire donc il faut en profiter
il faut il faut le faire je pense de
suite en tout cas ça a l'air vraiment
intéressant
voir ce que c'est qu'il nous fait
qu'on avait laissé le module est-ce
qu'on peut enlever merci de façon
l'évaluation j'ai compris quoi la barre
on fait la laisser mais de toute façon
en fait j'ai une grosse indication pour
nous le hier ça marche même pas le
module ok
il marche quasiment pas
donc du coup
on a une séquence très logique de Maxime
qui est pour moi le petit plus classique
de ce genre de position il a fait A4
c'était assez logique pour pour enlever
cette pression un petit peu nauséabonde
et à 5 c'est un excellent coup
positionnel pour bloquer le pion A6 sur
le long terme
et en plus en cas de baisser
de B prend ses trois B prend ses trois
vous avez tourbé à un moment ou quelque
chose en Bag avec le fou B7 qui embête
et pour l'instant il y a plus rien à 5
en l'air mais on va vraiment pas très
content les fous ces quatre que nous a
indiqué stouf bah ça va faire mal avec
le pion à 6 position très agréable
il y a des idées intéressantes en tout
cas les pièces blanches me placer j'ai
plus de possibilités donc Maxime qui est
qui est pas mal ici il est toujours à
peu près égale ce genre de position mais
humainement parlant bah c'est vraiment
très agréable et avec ouais pour les
blancs on s'ennuie on sait pas trop
comment prendre la position parce que
les pièces les positions genre trop bien
avec la tour en B1 le four en dessin tu
vois et au final ben il y a une pression
un peu diagonale qui peut arriver là tu
rends bien qui tape B7
c'est d'ailleurs pour commencer
[Musique]
il sait que ce fou à un moment donné
sera sûrement en danger et du coup bah
il anticipe un peu tout ça et il place
ça tourne en B8 donc
il essaie de provoquer bcbc je pense
parce que l'ouverture de la colonne B va
profiter au blanc qui pourront amener
plus de pièces sur les dames facilement
le fond des 5 adamora 4 et la Tour
Eiffel qui arrive
c'est les Noirs manquent un petit peu
d'espace dans cette position ou d'accès
aux cases et ça va suffire pour pour
mettre un pressing en place ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'on peut jouer
vite avec les Blancs aussi
c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment position assez
simple pour les blancs du coup donc pour
jouer vite et pour poser des problèmes
un peu pratiques et salut aussi cigogne
hello comment vas-tu
je crois qu'on veut bientôt d'ailleurs
c'est qui gagne
il me semble qu'on se voit bientôt
et puis maintenant que je vois je trouve
que les Blancs beaucoup d'initiatives
une des techniques qu'on peut vous
donner dans ces cas-là c'est d'échanger
les pièces donc pourquoi pas une
séquence cavalier dessin vous dessinez
peut-être pour vraiment
[Musique]
ouais comment ça échanger les pièces
maintenant c'est beaucoup d'efforts et
j'ai toujours pas réglé tous mes
problèmes dans cette position il y aura
toujours les dégâts
qui va toujours être un petit peu à une
cible tu vois c'est d'autant plus que si
on perd raciste tout on a perdu la
partie parce que le pion A5 il va
s'envoler quoi enfin il sera vraiment
hyper dur salut le bulle
le Bullet terrifiant
aujourd'hui on voit les bulles à
terrifiants
ok bon en tout cas une position Maxime
va presser il y a 3 minutes d'avance à
la pendule c'est quand même enfin ça
commence à faire déjà une position très
très simple pour lui à jouer la position
elle est peut-être parlons de l'égalité
mais en pratique c'est beaucoup plus
facile à jouer pour les blancs que pour
les Noirs donc du coup c'est ça va
favoriser à ce niveau là et puis je
pense qu'il peut il peut nous ramener la
victoire ici Maxime
est-ce que il va presser il va presser
c'est une position à deux résultats déjà
ça c'est intéressant pour vous de voir
voilà c'est la position moderne par
excellence avec les Blancs position
facile à jouer 3 minutes d'avance à la
pendule et position à deux résultats
parce que ça a l'air difficile à perdre
avec les Blancs on est vraiment contrôle
de la position surtout pour un joueur
comme Maxime évidemment complètement
est-ce qu'on irait pas voir un petit peu
ce qui se passe chez Carson on a
on a
on a la partie table 1 avec deux joueurs
qui ont 4 et demi sur 5 car sinon une
Forest en plus one forest c'est le
préparateur de de 45 donc
on va voir rapidement si vous voulez un
petit peu ce qui se passe chez cancer
une caméra en plus sur eux je vous mets
la caméra qui qui va avec
non parce que la position est
relativement ouverte et les noirs on la
perte de fou
qui semble intéressant d'autant plus
qu'il y a l'affaiblissement sur 15
blanche de la case G2 et ce qui est
rigolo c'est qu'on voit que la jauge
parce qu'on peut pas l'ignorer cette
jauge elle indique une bonne avantage
bonavantage blanc malgré la paire de fou
chez les Noirs attention
nous dit que qu'il y a pas une de salon
entre entre
est il y en aura jamais en fait surtout
en jakarten il veut jouer tout le temps
blanc noir il va jouer et surtout avec
les Blancs tu vois une combinaison déjà
presque gagnante ce que vient de jouer
enfin Magnus que se passe-t-il sur un
coup de Dame du style dame spécial j'ai
juste bouffé des quatre et je dis bah
file-moi ta paire de fou je pense que
c'est ça son idée et en fait
est-ce qu'il y a un intérêt de prendre
du cavalier eux non mon cavalier en C6
va peut-être se faire gêner ouais moi
j'aime bien parce que tu vois tu peux
toujours apprendre le FK et avoir plus
de liberté du style si tu fais dames C7
[Musique]
normal
faut prendre et tu as quand même réussi
à manger deux pions pour la qualité tu
as deux pions au centre avec les pions
ici tu as le fou aussi ce qui est pas
stable
de cavaliers et les pions qui vont
avancer tous ensemble je pense que c'est
c'est un ballantage pour les blancs ici
et en plus c'est typiquement les
positions que Carlson adore
et en plus tu vas vendre forest qui lui
adore les pollutions où ça bouge
beaucoup ben là malheureusement c'est il
est vraiment dans le côté où il est il
est un petit peu oppressé tu vois
prendre de la valeur en plus il y a le
problème c'est très dur à jouer sans
doute hein cette position même si le roi
bien sûr blanc est affaibli en fait il
est très difficile d'en profiter parce
que fou des seins qu'il y aura cavalier
4 comme sauf nous l'a indiqué qui
contrôle la cage G2 qui attaque le fou
donc on sait nous qui avons le pressing
ici et je vois que dans le chat ça
s'inquiète ça s'inquiète de
de ma doudoune mais j'ai décidé tout
pour tout dire de la mettre que pour les
les derniers jours de chaque de chaque
championnat parce que la doudoune c'est
vraiment quand même la tenue officielle
c'est un peu comme un costume lors d'une
remise des prix et effectivement
Migri il y a aussi un dress code pour
pour les streamers du coup là ma
meilleure tenue c'est pour pour le show
du dernier match de des derniers matchs
pour le titre en fait pour le titre il y
aura la doudoune je vous promets
d'ailleurs il y a un dress code dans le
tournoi on en a parlé parce
qu'hier du coup on
attendait quand même Sébastien Mazet
venir avec sa tenue de capitaine tu vois
et il ne l'a pas fait et du coup en fait
il y a un dress code sérieux et il faut
être habillé en noir en blanc chemise
Costa enfin c'est vraiment ouf quoi
tu peux pas être habillé en couleur vive
tu vois genre je viens j'ai j'ai un
t-shirt rouge bah bon quoi
je pense que ça passe pas non plus non
plus
ok en tout cas Carlson qui fait une
petite Master Class là et et bon c'est
clairement pas fini encore mais j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup ce qu'il fait alors on
va revenir un petit peu si tu veux voir
ce qui se passe chez nos Français oui et
c'est monstrueux parce qu'on a encore
une partie sa cuisse de qualité
professionnelle quoi chaque partie de
Carlsen reste
un grand moment positionnel quoi
c'est tout ce qui fait à chaque fois
tout ce qui arrive à créer c'est juste
incroyable
est-ce qu'on retrouve un peu nos
Français
enfin il y a eu la même si juste pour
voir ah il a pas mangé
ok il a pas joué
il faut prendre c'est un enfin
tu veux juste prendre les cases noires
peut-être les cases blanches essayer de
un petit peu risqué c'est que je
pourrais très bien jouer F4 maintenant
peut-être
et puis c'est un peu la même
je l'aime pas mais c'est un peu la même
pour nous tu vois enfin l'idée
parce que
je pense surtout B3 je peux manger ici
mais je peux faire des deux je pense ah
oui bah ça sera la même chose
voilà on a une dame chacun enfin une
pièce chacun comprise si tu bouges ton
fou je bouge mon cavalier en D4 ou en E5
et si tu si tu manges ici ben je vais
juste manger en F4 sûrement comme ça tu
manges comme ça aussi bref là je suis
gagné
[Musique]
donc F4 a l'air d'être un coup hyper
intéressant
[Musique]
sachant que
3 n'est pas n'est pas possible à cause
de Dame des deux je pense parce que
après ça faut voir donc ça c'est pas mal
aussi
ce qu'on peut jouer dame C6
il y a 26 là aussi j'avais prévu qu'il y
a des cartes moi ici
qui gagne la partie je pense ouais
donc FG5 là il y a peut-être
dans F3 c'est pour ça qu'il faut jouer
Dame des deux avant comme tu l'as dit
c'est pas simple
[Musique]
c'est compliqué vous voyez c'est le
bordel c'est ultra compliqué la tête
j'ai juste ça en fait et du coup tu as
plus de 15 pour la dame
de trois en plus
et au pire souvent là et bon
ça peut se compliquer très très vite
les choses
on a une pièce d'entreprise chacun vous
voyez et puis on Descartes et on peut
pas le défendre en fait c'est la partie
regarde ce qui s'est passé
il y a eu
il y a eu F4 ou P3 dame D2 t'apprend C6
prise table des 5 donc
là c'est complètement
G5 et puis avoir le pion C qui s'envole
mais on peut le jouer peut-être après
cavalier F4 c'est la totale quoi je
crois
ça a l'air très très
fort pour eux même si cela
ok allez on va on va changer un petit
peu peut-être un cavalier F4 oui on sait
très bien aussi alors cavalier
mais là non parce qu'il va te manger le
roi
et puis après je crois qu'il y a pas eu
le moment où le faire mais cavalier F4
ici est pas mal aussi tiracle
nous dit que Carlson a abandonné le team
mondial pour essayer de tout gagner
ailleurs moi gagner déjà beaucoup de
choses ailleurs ouais mais en fait c'est
juste qu'il était assez du cycle qu'il
gagnait aisément pendant des années
je pense qu'il reviendra parce que ça
reste quand même le Championnat du Monde
par excellence
mais il avait envie de faire une pause
par rapport à ça parce qu'il disait que
ça lui écoutait beaucoup de préparation
pour
pour finir pas grand chose sur lui enfin
pas grand chose parce que il s'est lassé
de gagner tout le temps quoi
du monde c'est pas grand chose mais
pour lui ça devenait ça devenait trop
d'investissement par rapport au retour
sur investissement et il se trouvait pas
en fait malheureusement il se trouvait
pas assez challenger c'est pour dire la
la main mise qu'il a sur ce monde des
échecs actuellement s'il avait joué
quelqu'un d'autre d'ailleurs que
que nepo
par exemple firoja il avait dit que ça
représentait un nouveau challenge
malheureusement firuja et était encore
un peu juste en terme d'âge et de de
maturité un tout proportion gardée par
rapport à cette élite là parce que
déjà
un super super crack mais pour aller
jouer un champion du monde contre
Carlsen il faut être réservé quand on
voit qu'au dernier cheval du monde n'est
pas mal chic il y a quand même été
brillant lors des deux tournois des
candidats qu'on vient de voir il n'a pas
réussi à devenir le choc du tout et la
sombrer pour devenir à la fin du
championnat du monde un joueur presque
lambda quoi donc c'est hallucinant ce
qu'il faut avoir en soi pour aller
affronter Carlsen aujourd'hui dans ce
type de
matchs franchement on l'a vu encore là
aujourd'hui un moment de Forest car
scène il y a toujours des positions
[Musique]
est-ce que tu tu veux qu'on fasse un
petit un petit top 3
c'est rigolo ce
pseudo power Guru parce que c'est
un grand maître français
sur plein de chasse à la base des années
donc du coup c'est rigolo
salut Malikou
salut à tous du coup est-ce que tu veux
te faire un petit top 3 qui vient
on a des choses à faire des petits Paris
on a on a beaucoup de sub en retard j'ai
tout mis sur un post-it d'ailleurs à la
maison dès demain faudra qu'on fasse les
comptes à la pause stoop je suis pas
chez moi mais
j'ai pas pu passer dans tes streams mais
en même temps tu étais beaucoup sur
chaise comme en ce moment et moi-même
pendant les vacances bah de toute façon
c'est un peu particulier mais après les
vacances on passera sur les chaînes
respectives vous savez qu'on aime bien
intéressé un petit peu le jeu et faire
les petits les petits Paris
d'autant plus que sauf m'a dit qu'il
aurait gagné beaucoup de subs grâce à
irigaizi hier alors finalement c'est
quand même mon partenaire de club alors
moi ce que je te propose ce que je
propose c'est qu'on se fasse
on se mette chacun un
podium et
que les
les par exemple moi je mets
ABC d'accord
et si un joueur arrive dans le podium
imaginons aussi a tu avais une troisième
donc moi je l'ai mis en premier et ben
je gagne quand même un truc parce que
bah je l'ai mis quoi par contre s'il est
sur la bonne place et ben c'est plus
c'est le c'est lui qui nous embête parce
que j'enseigne très fiable moi je vais
le mettre gagner
en fait on va à cause à cause de Magnus
et de ses résultats on va être malin et
normalement mettre plutôt les places 2
et 3 pour montrer la confiance qu'on a
c'est sûr
on va jusqu'au 4
deux trois quatre le podium
elle va que moi du coup je vais je vais
de ce pas
c'est quoi ça
c'est pas mal en tout cas Néandertal
nous fait une petite référence bonjour
@ power Guru elle va comment la méthode
[Rires]
c'était pas mal
ok alors moi je vais je vais commencer
mon petit Paris alors moi je mets un
quart de scène
de pas t'écouter
après deux
j'ai confiance en époque à ces cadence
là
il est pas là pour l'instant
il est toujours toujours en bus 4 quand
même
OK
j'ai trouvé des idées moi c'est bon moi
j'ai rempli mon moi mon tableau je vais
je vais dire en premier si tu veux
inspiré
sur ton papier ouais moi j'ai écrit
j'ai rien mais
et le cœur y est j'ai tout donné à
l'oral
je suis assez pragmatique
je vais mettre deux
[Musique]
d'accord parce que je n'oublie pas mon
cadeau rapide il a envie de faire
quelque chose
et je vais mettre
donc
[Musique]
fiable
Blitz sera différent mais
donc on reste sur des on est
complètement différent
il y a des gens qui m'intéressaient je
peux te dire Souf il y avait Mohamed
yarov
mvl il a déjà pris un peu de retard donc
je reste pragmatique c'est du Paris
donc je reste sur des choses
ok est-ce que tu veux le mien bien sûr
alors là je suis impatient justement en
plus ce qui est bien c'est qu'il y a des
différences c'est hyper différent dans
les trois que tu m'as annoncé un seul
qui est que j'ai mis assez bien
bien sûr et deux j'ai mis un joueur que
je soutiens depuis le début
surtout en ce cas là j'aime beaucoup
j'ai mis eghi je suis pas étonné parce
que c'était il restait dans la short
list et puis vous savez qu'il est tout
devant actuellement
ergy bah écoute il est capable de de
faire des grandes choses
en trois j'ai mis un
ok donc et on le cache aussi et en 4
j'ai mis un jour aussi bon c'est c'est
un peu le ouais c'est c'est un pari quoi
mais j'ai pris absolument
ce qui est les petits jeunes moi je
trouvais que c'était ils étaient
légitime aussi mais on peut pas citer
tout le monde
ok
on fait comment déjà du coup je trouve
plus propose que s'il est dans le truc
si par exemple je sais pas on dit on dit
Douda et que il arrive genre premier et
ben que tu gagnes pendant que ça
c'est le top 4 du coup on a révolutionné
ok nickel bah écoute c'est noté
c'est noté bon du coup Maxime qui Grint
d'envoyer à Maxime il a connu la
pression qu'on voulait avec le père avec
le pion insiste et on voit il y a
kubohème son anniversaire qui a plus que
45 secondes dans la pendule
la colonne C et du coup bah toute la
partie va rester sur ce pion à 6 vous
voyez la Jojo la jauge indique que c'est
pas assez mais en fait ça va être quand
même très pénible à jouer pour
adversaire en plus mais en fait vous
voyez que
d'un point de vue humain en fait
là on peut dire que ce que l'idée sur
laquelle je veux Maxime depuis le début
là on est au dixième coup l'idée c'est
de faire en fait A4 il y a un fil rouge
c'est vrai directeur dans cette partie
pour sur 5 et sur long terme travail sur
le pion en 6 en fait et là on va arriver
ça c'est au 10e coup là on va appeler
à s'organiser pour venir travailler
exactement
là on arrive d'ailleurs là on arrive on
est finalement au 28e coup tu vois donc
18 cours après et on commence à se
rendre compte un petit peu de l'idée de
Maxime du début qui avait été de pousser
à 5 pour affaiblir en fait le pion aussi
et un jour aller le manger quoi
un handicap on va dire pour son
adversaire qui va essayer de tenir cette
position il vient de jouer de très
intéressant c'est 6
Assomption à faible et peut-être que ça
va pas suffire
donc il veut créer des choses tout ça
mais il reste besoin de 10 secondes
c'est pas simple du tout sur dame B4 tu
aurais même prises en dessin aussi qui
pourrait être possible peut-être puis on
sait si c'est logique tours C6 et après
on travaille sur des 6 et 6
parce que sur ton coin à 5
malheureusement je mangeais ici et
manger des chips ça serait vraiment très
très fort et du coup trop fort donc ça
il faut manger ici la Tour de France
mais ce pion est faible et en le pion
décidé de faire aussi arriéré donc les
deux pions sont très faibles donc je
pense que la prise en décisif
et assez normal
de qualité j'imagine mais on a raté ah
là
ok ouais pourquoi pas évidemment
mais c'est vrai que c'était assez à
cette thématique d'ailleurs c'est une
bonne remarque de Power Guru
on pouvait aussi jouer différemment
parce que la dame elle a plein de cases
donc cavalier H4 se regarde ici donc je
sais pas où il faut mettre justement
par contre sur cavalier H4 effectifs ça
pose une question là dessus et ça me
laisse aussi un petit matin
donc du coup peut-être dame E3 qui va
venir
F3
ça continue encore des idées de pressing
évidemment parce que là j'ai dame G6 et
sur dame G3 cavalier 3 donc à chaque
fois il y a des
complications fortes ouais mais j'ai
quand même une bonne une belle position
j'ai envie de dire
je suis pas sûr que tu vois ce soit
grave peut-être pour sinon
E4 aussi le roi un peu faiblard je sais
pas peut-être la F6 et en tout cas très
intéressant ton ton
truc alors
si Dame G5 cavalier F4 je préfère jouer
pour passer la tour
c'est un peu pareil sauf que là du coup
tu me laisses plus maths comme tout à
l'heure donc là
tu vas dans l'idée j'ai plus besoin j'ai
plus peur en fait de
une très très bonne remarque
positionnelle
4 et en train de presser un petit peu
mais il a pas trouvé à la solution
évidemment il y a deux faiblesses des si
c'est à 6 et il va travailler autour il
va travailler votre nom des pièces lui
la zéro fait peur son paradis que quand
même
oui alors il y a le pion A5 c'est quoi
ce stuff je pense qu'on pourrait le
prendre dans ce cas là sur MP3
j'ai vérifié quand même parce que tu
sais qu'il peut y avoir flottement
commun c'est ça et là peut-être tour B4
et 3 peut-être dame C3
qui joue le joueur avec si peu de temps
attention
on peut même retourner un petit peu les
choses parfois mais très très beau jeu
noir bon les noirs
bien leur pièce qui qui ont beaucoup de
contre jeu et quand même Maxime qui a
quand même deux minutes 30 contre 27
secondes pour que Maxime m'a fait une
partie de grande qualité mais ça va
peut-être pas suffire pour vous montrer
à quel point c'est dur les échecs de
haut niveau
qui gagne toujours ça c'est clair mais
pour tout le reste et on sait que Maxime
c'est c'est un génie du jeu et ben
malheureusement on voit que c'est pas si
facile que ça il a trouvé une jolie idée
autours
est-ce qu'on peut voir comment
les noirs qui jouent Magnus a déjà fini
je crois
ils veulent manger des six et il se dit
que cavalier j'essaie peut-être pas et
ça c'est vraiment zéro chance si c'est
quelqu'un qui allait des chances de gain
c'est plutôt les Noirs je pense que
c'est zéro chance de gain des deux côtés
l'activité va va permettre au blanc
d'égaliser facilement cette position
depuis on a pour être dangereux
5 c'est un coup pour
pour déjà dire que voilà donc ça va être
ça va échanger et c'est ce que Maxime a
vu et puis bon il a dit bah j'ai pressé
mon adversaire a bien joué hallucinant
parce que il y a vraiment mis de la
pression mais pas suffisant quoi
le jeu avec je le vois pas jouer des
coups comme ça pour pour exactement ça
peut être risqué après
il peut essayer mais il voit que bah il
sait que son adversaire n'est pas un
manche du coup
c'est que des choix extrêmement forts
parce que faut bien dire que Maxime il a
trois et demi sur cinq dans ce tournoi
l'adversaire aussi
c'est pas top 10 mondial mais c'est ils
ont fait nulle tout de suite voilà ça
fait logique est-ce que tu voudrais voir
rapidement la partie de Mazet la joie
qui peut coup de pièces
je sais pas donc Néandertal nous nous
fait part du fait que nous rappelle que
donc Maxime ne va plus s'entraîner avec
Étienne maquereau
donc il y a un changement d'encadrement
qui est en place bon je pense que ça
change rien dans sa façon d'aborder un
rapide quoi ah oui non c'est là
c'est encore tout frais non on va voir
un peu ce qui se passe de toute façon
ok donc la source est deux donc c'est
qui presse aussi vous voyez il a un pion
à deux cases de la dame
et ça changera plus sa manière
d'ailleurs d'aborder les ouvertures je
pense que
[Musique]
va changer le reste du jeu ok peut-être
certaines choses que je ne vois pas mais
bon pas assez cadence là
bon Sébastien un gros pressing aussi
alors il cherche à savoir si c'est roi
BK ou roi des 4
ouais
maintenant je crois que c'est il va se
cacher
je leur dis qui est un peu moins
confiante que que moi mais voilà le fait
de pouvoir amener le pion imparablement
j'ai l'impression faut vérifier en C7
d'avoir la tour active sur la sur la 7e
rangée si j'arrive à faire ces 7 j'ai
envie de dire je vais gagner quoi et tu
sais le roi BK c'est très intelligent
dans cet optique là alors que roi
Descartes paraissait plus naturel d'un
point de vue final centralisation du roi
la son objectif c'est de passer le roi
en B6
[Musique]
pour voir ce sein quoi ça gagne parce
qu'on peut matière
ok bah bravo Sébastien qui qui gagne
cette partie et du coup qui se place
avec
avec du coup maintenant 4 sur 6 pour
Sébastien
légitime il était favori de cette partie
et maintenant il va taper au et on va
voir s'il va avoir du répondant contre
un des une des stars alors Jules du coup
a une qualité de plus alors attends je
veux voir rapidement ce qui s'est passé
je regarde très vite en arrière pour
voir donc il y a bien eu les coups c'est
que tout ce qu'on attendait c'était
vraiment bien des blancs de
l'appartement adversaire donc là du coup
c'est une position compliquée avec
recomposée du coup on est noir qui qui a
gardé les pièces
pour attaquer son adversaire il a été
assez brillant
et en défense il a il pensait qu'il y
avait rien du tout ici bon je vais assez
vite parce que là il faut qu'on
rattrape le direct là
bon là il y a eu des trucs qui se sont
passés il a refusé la répétition
et au final assez blanc pour ça
très très beau sacrifice de qualité pour
ouvrir le roi le roi noir mais au final
c'est vrai que les problèmes aussi sur
le 3 du coup les plans
dans l'esprit c'était vraiment bien joué
et G4 ok donc
c'est un peu plus facile pour les Noirs
sauf je sais pas ce que tu en penses
maintenant oui tu vois que il y a des
colonnes ouvertes un peu de partout que
le roi noir bon il est toujours un peu
en danger ça peut toujours arriver mais
il y en a quand même assez sécurisé le
pion passé qui fait attention à ça donc
le roi blanc
quand même qui est qui est aussi plutôt
bien plutôt bien défendu alors
en tout cas fait d'ocif et
erikasi sont en train de de se la coller
on voit l'écran encore qui a grosse
bataille parce que ça a l'air de jouer
très très vite et fait dossière qui nous
a ramené quelques tenues excentriques
qui doit être frustré apparemment nos
dînerandertal
des couleurs sobres
et c'est fini d'ailleurs entre fedoceïev
et regaizi
je sais pas si tu as le résultat stuff
je pense que les Blancs ont gagné je
pense que ce dossier a gagné
on va voir ça dans quelques instants on
l'a vu
[Musique]
de l'adversaire de Jules Moussa c'est un
peu du mal à y croire j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a des maths du couloir qui
escalier qui vont arriver chez les noirs
du style dame C4 tu vois c'est de
ramener une pièce sur la première fois
tu sais il y a des défenses à cavalier
F2 qui tiendrait beaucoup de cases donc
c'est aussi à ça et à ça pour empêcher
cavalier F2
[Musique]
mais bon
parce que l'option A6 est très avancé
d'accord ah oui il va crouter avec tour
à trois c'est ce qu'il a vu
et mais attention que moi aussi je peux
que je peux te couper le roi donc
30 secondes il faut que je prenne une
décision très rapidement c'est pas c'est
pas que
donc je crois qu'il y a pas trop le
choix
j'ai 4 c'est très bizarre parce que
tourgé 3 échec c'est quoi ton jeu
j'ai pas le droit de prendre ça parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'on voit bien et
menace de faire roi B7 c'est ça
changer ses pions à cause de tout le
monde espion qui reste ici
et sur ça du coup en fait il pousse quoi
il y a pas de souci
tout ça non pour moi je pense que du
coup là il a un stop discrètement
ça va être dur si hyper celle-là mais il
va revenir il va revenir
j'ai 5 je viens qui peut revenir ici
après ton idée direct oui tout rêve de
faire attention soit je vois parce qu'il
y a toujours l'histoire de tour des
trois
si je pousse
mais j'ai 5 G6 G7 tu sais des fois des
choses comme ça tu vas peut-être venir
me chercher
et la pousser en tout cas il trouve de
contre-jour bien joué donc là il a fait
maintenant ton ranger 3
la différence
parce que tourgé deux maintenant tu
reprends on reprend Rossi 6 ouais mais
ça fait nul ça quand même moi j'ai trois
et roi F5
il faudrait que je fasse dame sur la
chèque mais bon
il faut calculer là il y a plus de temps
c'est très compliqué et là du coup là il
faut manger tu peux plus revenir en
arrière maintenant qui va avoir ça moi
je peux toujours faire ça et ça tu vois
oui ça marche bon
ça ça
et après aller manger le pion avec la
tour qui défendrait aussi à 7 c'est pas
c'est pas idiot non plus
[Musique]
et il va falloir l'idée de qu'il a eu
avec ça mais maintenant ça va libérer le
roi blanc aussi ou si je fais tout rose
du coup pour empêcher le roi noir
désactivez ici
comment en fait tu joues
ton roi
tout moment où il a fixer la tour ce qui
est comme le plus logique et on libère
le roi c'est vraiment très très logique
ouais
il est très actif
ça vaudra de rendre le pion G7
OK
on devrait assister à la nuit Jules qui
aurait tout tenté pour
pour bien montrer ça c'est que même
contre des joueurs extrêmement forts
voyez que Jules qui se dit que il a un
petit Edge par rapport à son adversaire
il essaie de faire mal
ça va faire nul et on voit quand même se
passer qui qui a 4 points sur 6 quand
même VL
et qui ont laissé Jules du coup trois et
demi je pense à faire mieux cette partie
c'est un même presque les presque les
blancs qui peuvent qui peuvent pousser
si on fait des mots si on fait des
mauvais coups on peut juste se retrouver
dans le pétrin mais bon juste en attente
je pense qu'attendre comme ça c'est 4 va
faire mieux c'est tranquille quand même
d'ailleurs
on a dos Santorin fait et Douda qui joue
ensemble cette partie on va aller on va
aller voir ce qui se passe bien
[Musique]
et
du coup un deux un trois quatre il y a
une pièce de plus pour homme sur ton
offre
la poubelle quand même le pion qui va
vite arriver en A7 mais attention que le
roi arrive vite quand même et j'ai pas
beaucoup de pions à retourner j'aime
beaucoup
ça a l'air complètement en dessin
ça a l'air foutu mais pourquoi la jauge
ne doit pas marcher ce que je me dis
hein j'exclus à jauge de mon esprit je
me dis la chose je devrais tout en haut
à mon avis
parce que je fais ça ça et ça enfin
juste c'est fini quoi
c'est plutôt mauvais pour mes affaires
ouais bon ok a perdu hein
il est tellement sérieux et concentré tu
vois là j'ai vu hier une interview de
lui après avoir 202 et donc on lui
demande un peu bah si il est content
d'être là
s'il est content de son jeu etc ces
ambitions et bien sûr il veut gagner
hein et il a dit ouais comme tu as gagné
une dernière est-ce que tu penses se
réitérer l'exploit et il a dit ben moi
je m'en fous moi je suis juste là pour
bien jouer d'échec ouais j'avais vu
j'avais vu ce petit épisode et c'est
beau de dire ça c'est bien
tu vois en plus il est jeune quoi tu
vois il est jeune il est déjà hyper
mature en fait et sauf comment on fait
pour gagner avec les blancs en fait là
ben en fait je vais manger faire ça avec
la caverne en bêtises mais il y a roi
des six regarde tu vois et j'avais pas
vu
et du coup du coup tu sais c'est le
fameux truc qui n'arrive jamais dans nos
parties mais dans les leurs
c'est pas c'est pas si facile à gagner
cette histoire en fait
ce geste
j'étais en train de me dire mais comment
je fais maintenant que j'ai cette
position tout va bien
et en plus oui faut jamais jouer tout à
cet à cause de tour D8 sans doute donc
maintenant en vrai avec 22 secondes elle
a la pendule
je me dis que finalement cette position
on avait pourtant l'indication de la
jauge mais on se disait que c'était sans
doute le bug mais si on réfléchit bien
c'est pas si facile
j'avoue que ça veut dire ça
les pions GF machin c'est chaud j'ai 4
on voit que j'ai quatre étés
c'est le coup logique et du coup
mon abandonne notre poste du pion a tu
vois sauf donc c'est pas si facile que
ça bref 6 voilà
prise 7 peut-être
et le Roi peut revenir 5 tu vois sauf la
finale le roi cavalier tour évidemment
vous savez que c'est nul si vous savez
pas en règle générale c'est nul voilà
il faut faire très attention là
attention que j'ai toujours
un peu le jeu
incroyable de
ici
c'est incroyable 5 du coup va être joué
sûrement et 3 peut-être 38 pour mettre
le
mais attention que si j'arrive à faire à
7 puis tour sur 7
[Musique]
mais en fait comment je mets
c'est compliqué parce que ton bouge le
cavaler là
ça dépend où tu vas
mais ok ils vont encore être pressé avec
les avec les noirs et tout ça qui fait
un peu la tronche j'ai l'impression
tu vois il est pas content d'avoir
laissé Cavalia ici il a peut-être oublié
cavalier à 6 parce qu'il avait tout à
l'heure je pense qu'elle a raté
que c'est encore une fois c'est égalité
et on a dû rater un truc encore une fois
on comprend pas
pour là du coup va être joué sûrement
avec menace tour ici
il faut encore être précis parce que ça
c'est pas si simple encore j'ai
l'impression
attends
il répète parce que je pense qu'il avait
raté cavalier si je sais pas tout mais
la caméra en grand si vous voulez
peut-être
cavalier B8 alors cavalier B8 c'était
quoi
on a préféré répéter cette position
je vais mettre la caméra en grand c'est
plus sympa
je pense un peu plus sympa et de mes
cavaler un baby
[Musique]
c'est rigolo ça
très très rigolo ce qu'un
ce que je fais avec les Noirs maintenant
voilà on va jouer au roi pion
[Musique]
pour la fin de la partie
vous aimez pas
moi j'aime bien
moi j'ai bien joué je vous remets du
coup là abandon
tu sais ce qu'il faut au moins jouer H3
je trouvais que c'était pas si logique
de délier les pions il est pas content
dedans parce qu'il sait qu'il vient de
je vous ai remis la transition enfin un
truc normal désolé j'ai fait un test ça
m'avait l'air pas mal
pour le diagnotte quand on voit bien les
joueurs comme ça en grand et oui Cyril
le changement du monde toujours en
course clairement c'est clair il a il a
du coup 5 sur 6 du coup dans ce dans ce
championnat du monde
tout ça son implication sont sérieuses
c'est ça donne vraiment envie de de
parler sur lui encore une fois et donc
si on fait nos petits scores de français
du coup mvl sur 6 4 sur 6 Seb
c'est ça
[Musique]
elle avait été effectivement
maintenant que je l'a perdu on a raté ce
moment là en disant que oh là là elle
est vraiment perdu en plus
c'est même pour un champion comme Jules
on a envie toujours quand on est un peu
au dessus de continuer des fois on se
fait pigeonner avec souffle on
connaissait
[Musique]
connaissance que ça risque de d'être le
gros tilt qui arrive
maintenant il ne joue plus rien
en fait
il aurait fallu peut-être aller chercher
et peut-être plus le temps d'aller
chercher le pied ça peut être dangereux
pour lui hein si bien sûr c'était sûr
que ça allait très très dangereux
incroyable vu là Jules qui qui perd
cette partie c'est juste incroyable du
mal à comprendre
il a trop forcé il a trop forcé il y a
pas accepter que la pollution était
nulle a voulu gagner à tout prix il a
compris
mon conseil et du coup et il a pas joué
pour la nul en fait sur le long terme il
est gagnant de faire ça mais
ça peut mal se passer c'est bien contre
tous contre tous les plus faibles les
joueurs forts ils jouent très longtemps
pour faire craquer et de temps en temps
ça joue contre effectivement
c'est clair alors on va voir un peu le
résultat rapidement bon la France si on
a déjà vu mais sinon au niveau des
joueurs on a 45 qui vient de battre
ventes forest on a Kemer qui a battu car
wanna c'est la surprise du jour
on a vu qu'il a battu duda a mine vide
nulle fait de cire qui m'arrigazie m'a
dit
Sion nul mvl on l'a vu
martiniosur Artémis nul il y a plein de
nul donc rapport
nulsan
il vient de faire nul contre un tout
jeune joueur
nan qui a gagné la première partie
mais il maintient de battre son
compatriotes Christopher you
je vois rapidement là donc ok bah
écoutez
un petit point sur classement peut-être
je passe on peut vous le montrer je vais
voir si le classement non le classement
il est pas il est clairement pas à jour
parce que du coup il reste encore des
parties qui sont en train de jouer je
crois on va voir très très rapidement
s'il y a des parties encore qui jouent
en tout cas Jules doit être hyper déçu
maintenant à 3 sur 6 même s'il le
tournoi est très très long
ça va être dur de se remobiliser pour
pour la suite faut qu'il gagne toutes
ces parties aujourd'hui et puis voir
demain mais bon
c'est maintenant un joueur à qui il va
falloir
compter évidemment on est bien d'accord
avec cette remarque alors juste Carsen
il a il a gagné donc il a il a 5 sur 6
dans ce temps-là pour l'instant
5 et demi non je touche
5e sur 6 excusez-moi oui désolé je dis
n'importe quoi
c'est un système suisse je crois bien
oui système suisse 5 4 pour répondre à M
phase on est d'accord donc 5 5 grands
d'hier 4 ondes aujourd'hui et cadront le
dernier jour j'ai pas dit de bêtises
tout ce qui nous fait un total de 13
secondes c'est bien ça voilà donc voilà
Kemer c'est prodige grands prodige
allemand qui vient de passer la barre de
2700 hello en particulier
et
[Musique]
alors roi H4 donc là on a est-ce que les
gens qui sont la caméra vous pensez que
c'est c'est les joueurs qu'on a ici
c'est possible mais le sauf que le petit
c'est la position ouais c'est la
position donc on a le petit qui a l'air
d'avoir 10 ans qui a 2400 et l'eau
[Rires]
mais ce qu'on a la position les Noirs
c'est 24 68 on va bien et ben je t'aime
G4 et le petit c'est pas quel âge il a
ce qu'on peut regarder sur sur Google
est-ce que quelqu'un peut nous gobeler
moi-même et d'ailleurs marqué là quoi ça
m'intéresse il y a déjà qui dit que
Steph tu es est-ce qu'on t'a déjà dit
que tu es un sosie de cryparian
c'est la première il a 12 ans le petit
mais je sais pas qui s'écrit rien mais
j'ai hâte d'aller voir quoi tu vois pour
mesurer
2400 € le gosse il est né en 2010
et
ça fait déjà d'ailleurs
[Musique]
depuis ouais ça fait quasiment un an
qu'il a arrêté Lola
en plus gros prodige gros produit ouzbek
en tout cas et je pense qu'il va pas
essayer de faire nul dans cette position
je peux vous l'annoncer il est pas là
pour gagner il a un pion qui va à dame
comme ça
d'ailleurs le joueur
noir c'est
un streamer aussi
c'est un streamer et qui je sais qu'il
est très très bon en blitzibulette
l'imposteur en tout cas elle est
complètement d'accord avec la remarque
de giatcho donc j'ai hâte
de voir ça
tripariane donc réparer un
on va regarder moi je vais Google aussi
hein
je vois pas en quoi je lui ressemble
mais c'est pas trop un compliment vrai
je te remercie quand même
d'aller voir ça tout pour
la ressemblance en plus je la vois pas
du tout
enfin pas
[Musique]
plus avancés forcément au Bono canadien
ah oui monsieur c'est totalement mes
racines en plus
c'est bien ce qui me semblait ah oui moi
je suis robot Canada moi je j'ai du sang
roumain et aussi canadien dans les
veines
mais peut-être que tu joues un peu comme
un roumano Canadien aux échecs
par rapport au style de jeu qui t'ont
reconnu alors ça ça c'est une
possibilité
je sais pas trop ce que ça
représenterait aux échecs ce style
roumano canadien mais
c'est plutôt le joueur qui est le bon
techniquement j'ai envie de dire ça me
parle ça ça me parle et moi ça me
rappelle par rapport à moi
canadien j'ai du mal à définir et le
style roumano canadien encore plus tu
vois je me suis perdu après parce que
moi c'est quand même généralement
mauvais en ouverture et plutôt bon
techniquement c'est vrai par contre
canadien c'est trop loin de nos de chez
nous on sait pas trop mais du coup le
mieux
c'est bâti c'est salut Ruth j'ai vu
route tout à l'heure sur le chat aussi
magnifique que Cyril vient de nous dire
c'est magnifique en finale et en plus
particulièrement final de dames Cyril
c'est pas le nombre de pions qui
comptent mais le pion le plus avancé
ouais donc là c'est vraiment en finale
de dames c'est très bien dit parce que
là du coup c'est vrai que c'est c'est
c'est dangereux on peut pas laisser un
temps au noir parce qu'ils font d'âme
alors que nous on est quand même pas
loin aussi mais le problème c'est que la
dame noire contrôlerait la dame blanche
et en plus après c'est même si on
arrivait à faire dam dam et ben le noir
aurait le très avec deux dames fromage
et ça fait peur on n'a pas envie de
laisser le trait à l'adversaire
donc donc
en interposant sa dame par exemple et
gagner après la finale de d'option parce
que bon il arriverait avant
par exemple je sais pas un truc s'il y a
un moment donné il y a un échec pouvoir
venir cloué ou pouvoir faire un truc
si cette blitrine c'est une très bonne
remarque mais c'est en finale de dames
c'est pas dans toutes les finales que ça
marche
ça c'est important par exemple mais
c'est franchement pas si facile que ça
mais en finale de dames ça marche très
bien
et finalement il y a des exceptions de
partout tout le temps évidemment et et
c'est pas de et c'est pas de Kevin à la
base évidemment aussi on a inventé ça
mais
[Musique]
ça fait des lustres ça existe par
exemple dans les secrets de l'efficacité
aux échecs de John nun c'est une des
remarques principales en finale de dame
en conseil donné aux amateurs donc c'est
vraiment un très très bon conseil parce
que comme news il y a beaucoup
d'exception mais quand on a quelques
règles générales en tête bah ça nous
permet de mieux comprendre les choses
est-ce que je peux pas jouer une seconde
je pense un truc ça y est c'est en dame
là c'est ça qui gagne non
le roi noir regarde
ouf le roi noir et c'est pris la
tactique l'enfant a voulu contre
tactifier l'adulte et finalement
il vient de se prendre un triste
un triste coup d'échec qui peut faire
dingue maintenant et on peut faire dame
facilement et c'est gagné vous voyez on
va contrôler en fait en finale n'a pas
de dame C6 échec ou Dame des cinq on
peut pas faire promotion derrière
il fait quand même échec on a vu le on a
vu le petit
sur la table
et il y a une une remarque énorme de
Néandertal c'est comme si on voulait
attribuer l'invention de la roue tourne
à Ribéry
Néandertal nous gâtent à chaque fois
je pense que il serait content
2400 hello 12 ans
il se débrouille bien Sara chi mais
attention
6 secondes donc des fois quand on vient
de gagner quelque chose on peut
s'endormir il faut pas qu'il oublie à
pendule il a failli hein
je pense
en tout cas en tout cas c'est le métier
pour lui rappelez-vous de bug bug
muratov sera peut-être là dans la
première table dans quelques années mais
c'est encore un peu chaud cette position
en partie c'est pas encore claire il y a
parce que les dames sont mal placées on
dirait une étude tu sais c'est la pire
pire positionnement de dames possible et
je sais pas où il faut cacher son roi en
fait alors ou alors faut faire revenir
nos dames mais n'oubliez pas qu'il y a
la promotion voilà les deux les deux
dames contrôlent la case de promotion
quand même donc ça va être dur à vendre
sur dame parce qu'au début Stéphane je
voulais aller me cacher en alors
excuse-moi il a perdu contre Amin Bassem
donc 2700 perdu en 2500 perdus
Christiane scène qui a quasiment 2006
après la fin nul en 2300 et là il vient
me battre en 2200 donc il a rien fait
d'extraordinaire je pense par rapport à
son niveau
pour l'instant il perdrait un peu des
points et l'eau enfin il a 200400 feed
mais en blitz il a 22,67
il faut dire donc du coup bon voilà
il est 2400 ans oui oui donc le vrai jeu
pour moi c'est le long donc en fait il a
quasiment le niveau maternelle déjà quoi
quasiment il va l'obtenir si on est 2004
je peux vous dire qu'il l'a dans les
jambes le titre
donc voilà
donc il a rien de mieux sur 5 il a pas
joué des stars
salut madame
hello hello à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent
dans le brouillard
oh là là le craquage qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé attends attends attends attends
il y a une blague ou d'un échec
mais pourquoi il a pris pourquoi
c'est un truc de fou
et maintenant il essaie de faire nul
mais il y a nul quand même c'est un truc
de fou regarde le regard du petit là
regarde non mais comment regarder mais
pourquoi il a tout compris la position
regardez le piège de Bullet ça c'est
vraiment une stouffe ça c'est ouf ça je
le fais en stream tout le temps il a de
la dame pourquoi il joue pas roi Bessat
ça reste cool
je pense oui c'est ça je pense qu'il a
mal compté les pièces
et puis j'ai une dame de plus sauf que
comme il perd la sienne en plus de la
promotion c'est incroyable
incroyable quoi blender sur Blender
cette partie qui n'ont pas
bon il y a encore des choses
[Musique]
qu'on a pas de moyens de sortir du
réseau de perpétuel
c'est chaud quoi
c'était mignon
dans le chat beaucoup se servent des
citations de Ribéry visiblement pour
progresser aux échecs
très intéressant
je sais pas qui avait autant de fans de
passionnés des chats qui mêle les deux
l'utile à l'agréable
qui vient là j'ai chèque voilà échec en
fait toujours échec en D2 pour garder
chaque classe
et en fait
parce que là vous voyez que sarachi il a
pas du tout maîtrisé ce qu'il a fait il
est passé de gagnant annule mais ça
aurait pu être passé de gagnant à
perdant directement
mais
parti marrante en vrai les deux en plus
en plus ce qui est drôle tu vois c'est
que c'est quand même de voir qu'ils sont
très très forts 2400 hello 2468 il joue
quasiment dans la dernière étape du
tournoi et tu vois c'est un peu comme
toi par exemple quand tu vas un open
normal tu vas voir la dernière table et
tu vois que des fois ça joue des coups
très très bizarre et ça fait des grosses
gaffes etc là c'est pareil sauf que ce
genre à 2400 donc en fait tu vas voir 45
par un qui va avoir cette partie ils
vont se dire mais ils font n'importe
quoi tu vois là ça reste quand même des
mini et tout tu vois je trouve ça génial
en fait il y a de la bonne dans le chat
ça Ratchet c'était à la suite son plein
gré tu vois pour résumer cette cette
partie et chaos du MB 91 c'est pour ça
que je perds enfin 700 hello avec la
méthode Ribéry
on préfère la méthode Silma la méthode
Darkman et là et la méthode Ribéry qui
apporte pas assez pour l'instant voilà
on nous écoutant normalement tu devrais
petit à petit chaise du MB aller au
dessus de la méthode Ribéry
mais en tout cas elle était marrante
cette partie effectivement
et du coup c'est pas l'Internet les gens
sont en face à face
au final la boxe bons amis ils ont fait
nul avec une partie rebondissements donc
je pense que les les deux sont contents
de faire un nul et il y a encore une
partie en jeu hein encore une partie la
fameuse finale turfu ça va être
intéressant
donc qui normalement est nulle théorique
mais en pratique c'est très très dur
pour pour la tour de tenir surtout on
commencera rapide et
et tout ça quoi moi je l'ai eu deux fois
en partie celle là j'ai réussi à la
tenir deux fois
mais moi je l'ai une fois sauf mais je
l'ai pas gagné tu vois j'avais le tour
fou malheureusement
très facilement la roue tourne à tourner
pour Sarah Chypre bravo Cyril elle est
belle aussi
donc échec bon là du coup est-ce que ça
fait 50 cours alors du coup on a je vais
voir si on a une caméra parce que bah du
coup bah il reste une seule partie
peut-être la caméra aura changé donc on
rappelle un règle des 50 coups sans
prise ni poussette pion le match nul
peut être réclamé par le joueur qui
défend évidemment le joueur qui attaque
aussi mais bon aucun intérêt
malheureusement on n'a pas besoin qui
domine
va essayer de gagner cette position
prendre la tour ou mater avant la règle
des 50 coups sans prise ni poussée de
pion je pense que là tu regardes si je
veux aucune numéro 100
depuis longtemps ok ok ça marche bon du
coup non vous laissez on fait un petit
peu de 5 minutes la petite pause de 5
minutes
donc rester resté parmi nous pour le
dénouement de ce championnat avec un
Carlson Fredo CIF à venir parce que deux
joueurs à 5 et demi donc je vous
rappelle le score de français mvl 4 sur
6 Jules 3 Sébastien Mazet 4 sur 6
peut-être un duel
capitaine MVS ça pourrait être très très
marrant en tout cas on va voir donc il y
a eu un beau teaser de stuff qui nous
dit que il va y avoir le dénouement le
dénouement de championnat aujourd'hui
c'est pour vous faire rester mais
attention c'est juste la suite
c'est bien demain c'est bien demain quoi
donc on fait un double teaser
donc on a quatre rondes aujourd'hui là
on va commencer la deuxième et de
manière
donc ça va se passer
donc
c'est un énorme tournoi et là il va il
va taper du gros quoi donc et il est
capable de faire d'énormes parties
en 2007 plus exactement que apparemment
un plateau de fruits de mer m'attend à
Vannes soufflouf mais bon là je suis
coincé malheureusement là je peux pas je
suis dans le Finistère pour je dis
bonjour au morbihanais avant qu'on
prenne la pose la stouffe quand tu veux
c'est toi le chef technique vous
rappeler tout faire la baguette
yes c'est ça
c'est ça du coup bah nous on va passer
en pause et
puis alors juste le lien de chaise 24
on va on va essayer d'être
soft ici on est quand même sur cheesecom
donc je te remercie donc nous on part en
pause et je vous dis du coup ben à tout
de suite donc exactement si vous savez
pas quoi faire allez voir nos chaînes
aussi de respectifs il y a plein d'infos
pour progresser aux échecs ça va être
grand plaisir je vais mettre sur le sur
le chat en tout cas à tout de suite
allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec avec Kevin
du coup
exactement
il y en a qui ont été très très
attentifs dans le chat qui ont vu même
sur les slides quelques fautes de
français hop ça c'est c'est dit mais
nous n'a pas la main dessus un poids pas
corriger ce sera les mêmes slides à
chaque fois donc bravo à vous et surtout
vous nous avez donné l'appareil bon
peut-être le plus chaud pour nous en
tant que Français
de cette ronde là avec un mvl Mazet ou
plutôt Sébastien Mazet contre mvl yes et
mvl est obligé en plus de jouer pour
gagner ils vont pas non ça va pas faire
mieux faire une petite nulle surtout
assez cadence là alors c'est pas évident
aux échecs on se connaît de jouer
ensemble quand il y a un écart de niveau
ben voilà il faut jouer il faut
combattre et là dans ces cadences là de
Blitz c'est rapide je peux vous dire que
souvent il n'y a pas de de petites
nulles entre potes ça se fout sur la
tronche
voilà parce que parce que c'est des
cadences rapides et on est là pour ça
sinon ça sert à rien d'aller
au Kazakhstan autant rester à la maison
et passer les fêtes en famille si c'est
pour ne pas jouer aux échecs quand il y
a des grosses parties donc c'est ça ils
vont se [ __ ] sur la tronche par contre
c'est bastien va être normalement
je pense après je peux pas vous dire
mais il va être tourné sur un jeu plutôt
sec avec
normalement Maxime excellent calcul
Sébastien n'est pas mauvais dans ce
registre là mais ouais c'est Maxime
c'est un dieu du calcul donc il va
plutôt comme on l'a dit amener une
position plutôt stratégique plutôt temps
de faire la finale domaine où il excelle
même si Maxime c'est tout faire
évidemment mais il doit trouver une
ouverture il a les blancs il peut plus
imposer sa patte essayer de de faire mal
à Maxime avec une partie un peu chiante
il y a pas d'autres mots en fait bon
Sébastien il a été dans l'équipe de
préparation aussi de mvl donc en termes
de tu vois bah ça c'est ils sont amis
puis en plus ils ont travaillé ensemble
donc c'est pas évident pour ni l'un ni
l'autre de s'affronter mais il aimait
quand même que Maxime et beaucoup plus
fort que que Sébastien et du coup en
tout cas ce petit duel quand même assez
sympa je suis pas sûr que les Archanges
de jouer ensemble mais bon ça nous fait
plaisir en tout cas c'est toujours
pareil dans ces cas-là c'est nous on est
hyper content c'est marrant on se dit
que c'est marrant mais eux c'est ils
sont verts donc après donc ça me fait
plaisir mais eux je pense pas que c'est
la façon dont on arrête parce que Maxime
il veut absolument gagner pour revenir
un peu dans le peloton de tête
Sébastien bon il fait un bon tournoi et
du coup je pense qu'il aurait préféré
jouer quelqu'un d'autre parce que bah
Maxime il joue quand il veut et
il aurait peut-être aimé jouer un joueur
dans plus quelqu'un de plus accessible
rien qu'il ne connaît pas je mets facile
de de
[Musique]
Sébastien on n'aura pas la cam
malheureusement sauf s'il venait à jouer
une finale ultra longue mais là
j'ai que quatre caméras dans la première
table donc j'ai les quatre Martins en
caméra donc vous imaginez pas quoi parce
que Sébastien a fait un gros tournoi
mais il est un plus petit lot donc il
joue des gros joueurs donc gros tournoi
et Maxime inversement proportionnel
c'est un tournoi on peut pas qualifier
de de mauvais mais pour l'instant c'est
un tournoi moyen pour pour Maxime
clairement un stoop donc c'est pour ça
qu'il y a pas de calme le vin très bon
tournoi d'ailleurs plutôt je dirais il
est il est en dessous de ses capacités
habituel tu as faim
là il a quand même tu vois fait 4000 de
victoire
ça perd pas j'aime bien pourtant ce
genre de tournoi tu vois en même temps
regarde ce qu'il va faire là il fait nul
nul nul contre covalleft tabatabahi on
peut pas lui dire après il joue un mec à
moins de 2005 il le tape il joue un Mac
à 2006 il le tape et après il fait nul
prête que le joueur qui vient de jouer
là yakubuette lui amène la pression
franchement si je gagne là tiens tournoi
moyen puis il se laisse toutes les
chances de de rester en dans le match
ouais non mais il est tout il est il est
exigeant avec Maxime vous avez vu
le Maxime
genre tu vois
des fois ils sont obligés de faire le
dos rond quand les mecs défendent bien
tout ça
il est en forme il est si mise en scène
il joue hyper bien il massacre tout le
monde là on a un quartier d'enfant en
contrepartie on a un mvl qui n'est pas
très en forme et du coup bah ça sent
dans les parties dans les résultats et
bon après la tournée elle est pas fini
bien entendu
tu vois mais
Maxime peut largement revenir on avait
vu la dernière au Blitz le but a gagné
d'ailleurs et ben il a fait une
remontada de l'espace il a gagné je sais
plus mais c'était genre si par contre
d'affilée à un moment donné tu vois
c'est ça donc
mental et il peut clairement remonter en
tout cas il faut que ça commence par
cette partie là
c'est important en plus c'est une partie
il a pas perdu donc pour un joueur de
cette classe là tant que vous perdez pas
ne vous restez pour moi hyper dangereux
quoi c'est clair
on n'a pas réussi quand même battre il
est invincible donc ça peut ça peut
quand même être encore
LVM ça rime avec diesel peut-être mais
il est capable aussi de mais c'est comme
tous les jours de haut niveau comme la
distance dès qu'il commence à être un
peu en confiance et à enchaîner quelques
victoires ça peut ça peut devenir hyper
dangereux quoi c'est ça
en quelques secondes mais je dois juste
ouvrir un petit truc et je vous remets
Kevin voilà
et
non mais en fait du coup je pense qu'il
faut un peu de motivation des fois aussi
un petit peu de
on parle un petit peu de chance tout à
l'heure on est parti
tu vois mais c'est vrai que Maxime les
adversaires qui étaient même si bon
c'est le genre qui ont 2650 2016 c'est
pas les peintres tu vois
très solides qui veulent tous faire nul
contre Maxime tu vois quand tu joues un
koalaf tant que tu joues un tabac tabac
quand tu joues un
petit beau F enfin ils veulent 12 faire
du contre Maxine et du coup blanc noir
ben c'est dur de vraiment
mettre le point quand on a harcèle
seront rêve c'est de faire du contre toi
quoi et là la caméra on voit on voit
comment il s'appelle
truc mémoire
[Musique]
ça c'est le match des artistes les deux
joueurs qui sont très très créatif
absolument rien à voir
quand même aujourd'hui pas mal d'idées
de Sosie qui ont commencé donc du coup
on a on a c'est pas ça masse des contre
mvl avec E4 E5 du coup déjà c'est déjà
assez rigolo quand même
déjà c'est
très très étonnant comme choix de
Paris sur ça
qui favorise vachement la nul quand même
ouais réputé très très solide et si les
amateurs cette pétrole bah elle est
plutôt elle peut se jouer pour les trois
résultats on va dire à haut niveau comme
nous le disent tous là ça favorise
plutôt le jeu pour la nul donc c'est
très très étonnant comme choix de la
part de MVM parce qu'on avait dit qu'il
allait tout envoyer
fait tout ça il a des connaissances
énormes de coups du coup c'est une
partie entre copains où ils connaissent
bien leurs ouvertures donc ils vont
essayer de se faire bluffer contre bluff
un petit peu c'est ça ou pas on verra
mais ça peut vraiment être une histoire
comme comme celle-là
comment est-ce qu'on joue ici là
qu'est-ce qui va jouer tu penses
Sébastien ici
je pense pas qu'ils ont envie de faire
nul ce serait un peu décevant je pense
pas que Maxime soit là enfin nul en fin
de coup avec les
lignes il doit se demander pourquoi il
me fait ça regardez une minute de prise
par Sébastien
et lui aussi je pense que il s'attendait
pas à une
une telle ouverture
moins une prépa de ma scène connaît pas
barbo pourquoi pas mais
franchement
le truc c'est que c'est simple qui va
pouvoir choisir en fait en premier parce
que normalement il va faire cavalier
prend le 5 des 6 cavalier F3 cavalier.4
et déjà il pourrait jouer d'un deux
donc tu vois je trouve ce que je veux
dire c'est que bon il a joué qui a
laissé 3D ok je voulais les quatre
cavaliers potentiellement et s'il y a
fubéca qui existe mais c'est très
égalisant donc c'est les quatre
cavaliers
donc c'est une vraie partie cavalier des
cartes ça joints
et il y a fosse 4 qui existent il y a
une ligne marrante avec fusek4 qui avait
les points F3 je prends F3 que tu la
connaisses il y a beaucoup de choses ici
qui existent
qui est marrant mais en fait l'idée de
faire ton géant et empêcher un petit peu
le foot sortir à cause de cette et on a
vu Étienne Bacrot et d'ailleurs c'est
passé je vais beaucoup ça avec les
Blancs d'ailleurs et tu as mis une short
c'est rigolo tu nous dis italien ou
espagnol et en fait c'est une carte
cavalier donc on sort les quatre
cavaliers c'est ni espagnol ni italienne
c'est ça c'est les quatre cavaliers
c'est spécifique en fait
rien qu'un cavalier développé de chaque
côté naturellement peut changer peut
faire changer de nom à la position et à
l'ouverture
[Musique]
qui a vraiment c'est pas facile la
jungle des ouvertures pour pour les
joueurs amateurs et souvent la
littérature est chicane est très riche
malheureusement
c'est pas facile de trouver des bons
bouquins pour vous expliquer ou
vulgariser les ouvertures aux échecs
donc là c'est presque mieux de prendre
des petites vidéos pour pour les
ouvertures parce que je trouve que les
bouquins sont trop trop durs sauf si
vous êtes des joueurs aller à plus de
1600 1800 chevronnés vous jouez depuis
des années alors dans les livres vous
pouvez aussi trouver des choses mais
sinon je trouve que c'est un peu plus à
inaccessible je trouve
donc là c'est vraiment parce que c'est
vraiment une partie
entre deux
lignes avec avec E5 à la place de jouer
de jeu cavaliers 5 et c'est complètement
égalisant voilà pour le coup c'est la
ligne la plus nulle que tu puisses enfin
nul dans le sens égalisant tu vois pas
nul mauvaise et du coup un peu tenez qui
joue pas celle-là pense qu'il aura
c'est hyper solide et du coup oui
grandeur on peut plus faire ces trois D4
mais il y a pas que ça en différence
si tu veux le pion
E4 est protégé du coup fubé 5 menacé des
fous prends aussi ça que le gain du pion
E5 alors que dans l'espagnol il n'y a
pas ce thème là le gain du pion E5 est
contré par un Dame des 4 c'est difficile
d'expliquer ça l'aveugle mais il y a une
différence significative entre
l'espagnol et les quatre cavaliers avec
que l'on vient de voir
et
joli pseudo en tout cas Franky Finistère
Morbihan il nous dit l'ouverture la
Bretonne vous connaissez c'est très à la
douzaine voilà et moi qui suis
finistérien ça me parle tranquille très
très beau n'allez pas référencée par
contre dans la littérature et chicane
celle-là
voilà et Cyril qui rebondit aussi
c'est un tout jeune joueur c'est un
adversaire de
je me demande s'il est dans la catégorie
de Marc-André mauriti ou je dis
n'importe quoi
je crois que murdin c'est par exemple
les élus dans la dans un tournoi
ensemble mais des espoirs ou je sais pas
quoi c'est
discret en majuscule
un bon et maintenant je vais aux échecs
mais bon ça risque d'être un peu c'est
Causse ouais alors il y a une ligne que
moi je joue je peux vous la montrer
rapidement c'est E5 et en fait c'est
extrêmement égalisant prise ici il faut
il faut manger en F6 bon j'en ai deux
c'est c'est quasiment perdant en fait
pour les Noirs
même échec qui échange de dames et qui
fait nul juste direct
ça c'est 6 de 5 et c'est complètement
égal cette position
après il faut encore la tenir mais
normalement et du coup
caballer des 5 a été joué sur notre
ligne donc invalid prend E4 il ressemble
à deux
donc
un style qu'on les a vu au Challenger
qu'ils ont joué ensemble
qui ont joué ensemble
et le petit Marc-André
est-ce que ça te parle toi la petite
rêve de route qui nous dit qu'il faut
pas confondre Morzine et merzine non
est-ce que ça me parle non j'ai pas la
refaire
un groupe breton très très connu tout je
t'invite à les écouter à la prochaine
pause très très important ça marche ça
sera fait
voilà en tout cas il y a du breton dans
le chat aujourd'hui
on salue toute la région
vous voulez qu'on voit des parties en
particulier ou des trucs surtout
n'hésitez pas donc on va quand même
passer un peu plus de temps sur mvl
parce que c'est quand même le français
c'est lui qu'on suit en priorité après
si vous voulez bon on va aller voir un
peu des caresses des népots on va aller
voir un peu tout ça mais c'est pas la
priorité aujourd'hui on le fera aussi
mais on va plutôt récent casser mais
s'il y a des parties que vous voulez
voir en tout cas n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à nous demander ou si vous
avez des questions par rapport à par
rapport à une position des coups quoi
que ce soit surtout n'hésitez pas à nous
demander on vous répondra et on essaiera
avec vous
ouais après bon regardez là moi j'ai une
question sauf que qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette partie bizarre de mvl on avait
dit que que Sébastien allait chercher
une position assez sèche et en fait tu
as l'impression que tu as l'impression
qu'il cherche la nul c'est très bizarre
elle lui a donné cette position sèche
prêt à baisser rapide montre qu'il a
envie de jouer aux échec mais bon c'est
quand même bizarre
on peut pas JP 62 on n'a pas la caméra
de de mvl et Mazo parce que il joue très
très loin ils sont que table 20 même si
Sébastien réalise un très joli tournoi
il joue fort à chaque fois son hello ne
protège pas et mvl qui est plus protégé
lui fait un tournoi moyen
et Stéphane a envie qu'il fasse bien
mieux MVM il y a une grosse pression de
qui a été mise partout en fait tu vois
Sébastien il est plus là pour se faire
plaisir il fait un super tournoi et du
coup bon voilà quoi mvl il joue quand
même pour le titre au point un podium et
du coup ben si on enfin moi perso je
vois la partie j'aimerais bien que une
VL gagne pour voir où est-ce que enfin
tu vois il peut aller quoi
parce que Sébastien on l'aime tous il
est génial tout ça mais il sera pas
champion du monde donc alors que Maxime
boyley il a fait un départ un peu un
petit peu lent mais on sait qu'il est
capable de remontada et puis au final
c'est quand même un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde en partie rapide et
Blitz donc donc voilà donc la caméra
j'aimerais bien la mettre alors moi je
l'ai pas vous savez qu'on joue à bleu
dans cette partie très bizarre on peut
se demander finalement si si ça va pas
être avec quasiment obligé de jouer
normalement
donc je vous rappelle j'ai cinq caméras
à mettre une qui fait toute la salle et
et après quatre caméras sur les enfin
une sur les quatre premières tables et
Maxime le vin donc vous imaginez bien
que Maxime
apparemment il aura pas de caméra sur
lui pour l'instant en tout cas pas table
20 donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
j'ai pas que j'ai pas la caméra sur lui
mais
du coup bah sinon je l'aurais bien sûr
bien sûr mais Sébastien on aime bien
mais ça a pas champion du monde
enfin oui je voulais que je vous dise
c'est c'est la vérité il est il est il
est très fort il fait insupportun le
très content pour ça mais Maxime Maxime
donc en fait exactement exactement
[Musique]
favori dans ce match
et aussi un des plus gros
candidats au titre donc un défavorisant
quoi donc suite à ta remarque sur le
fait qu'on pouvait choisir des parties à
Charlie qui qui doit être assez facile
ceux qui nous a demandé où étaient les
joueurs bretons dans ce tournoi
ils sont pas malheureusement représentés
Charlie hier on en a parlé parce que
Barbie que c'était le chat et barbix il
a 2507 en rapide
et soit il a 40 points hello du
il y a de la marge il y a de la marche
il y a de la marche oui mais super
looping merci beaucoup c'est pour le
ping pour le sub
mais juste vous imaginez Barbie
Championnat du Monde
[Musique]
Barbie
le titre ce serait pas on suit un vélo
du squadou mon gars
je pense qu'il y aura un gros événement
de chez com et une communication ciblée
sur sur un des plus gros événements au
monde au niveau du jeu de chaque quoi ah
oui je pense que tout le monde le
suivrait quoi ça serait barbix ça serait
la star du porno quoi
je pense qu'il aura envie de le jouer
tout le monde veut le jeu
est-ce qu'il est sympa
se passe à almati au Kazakhstan il y a
des Français il y a 4 français il y a
trois Français tu vois tu as mvl Jules
Sébastien Mazet c'est trois Français
doit le score 406 406 et 3 sur 6
un peu décevant pour l'instant pour mvl
qui lui Ben fait partie des tout favoris
du tournoi
Jules aussi un peu décevant qui est
Jules qui qui peut être très surprenant
c'est qu'avant cela et par contre
Sébastien qui fait un tournoi très très
bon donc on Avel là
et les deux Français qui s'affrontent
dans ce tournoi donc il y a 200 joueurs
et il faut qu'il tombe ensemble donc
je pense qu'ils l'ont bien cherché au
final
j'aime bien quand même la position bon
c'est égal mais j'ai l'impression que
mvl peut faire des choses
et savoir plus d'espace avec sa part de
fou
je vois bien je grand rock ouais
chaque et on peut si on peut l'éviter
c'est
plutôt ok il peut aussi mettre son roi
avec f6r roi F7 ce tableau 12 excuse-moi
faites-moi sur moi son tableau 20 sur
TFK et effectivement sur
sur Chase
com c'est table 20 donc ils ont placé
enfin ils ont mis un ordre différent
mais sortir ce résolve effectivement
c'était le 12 donc ouais c'est vrai
c'est mais bon j'ai quatre caméras j'ai
quatre caméras donc
table 12 où 48 il y a pas de caméra
c'est c'est ça bonne source bonne source
résulte
ouais bon on s'ennuie quoi dans cette
partie franchement très sèche un petit
peu chez les autres parce que on
reviendra un petit peu
il joue
kadrichissement quand vous avez trois
sur 6 je peux vous le dire
ouais donc c'est une sorte un peu de
filigrane
C4
C6 alors H6
qui a été je crois qu'il y a d'ailleurs
elle a étudiée par par le symbole de
Queen Kai il me semble
H6 parce que il y a beaucoup de B6 qui
étaient lois avant il y a beaucoup de A5
qui étaient jouent aussi mais HC c'est
la nouvelle ligne à la mode
parce que ça c'est les petites je
regarde pas trop ça je regarde si il y a
deux 5 parce que c'est il faut beaucoup
d'expérience pour jouer ce genre de de
variantes ou vous avez moins d'espace
que que l'adversaire est tout peut jouer
ça depuis très très longtemps évidemment
pas de pluie du coup quand vous prenez
bien les thèmes ça fait peut-être deux
trois ans déjà beaucoup hein vous
imaginez deux trois ans d'expérience il
dit que c'est pas beaucoup à envoyer et
plus toutes ces années d'échec donc là
c'est c'est la totale c'est la folie
Barbie qui s'appelle Pierre Barbot voilà
on avait un Barbeau
sans eux voilà salut rezane
très bonjour environ 24 50 tout le temps
tout le temps Pierre 50 mais en rapide
il a 2500 hello
parce que on connaît pas trop
faire la bière
on profit qui prend l'avion il a pas de
wifi pas nous entendre
du coup qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce
qu'on peut aller voir un petit peu du
coup là on a vu les Français un petit
peu on va l'avoir un peu Carlson je
pense
donc c'est toujours un peu plus
difficile de jouer avec les noirs
et de déséquilibrer la position et il
est en train d'essayer
alors on a une ouverture
Bourgoin indienne pour ceux que ça
intéresse
donc c'est la cousine de la limonade
donc c'est une ouverture sur des 4 où
vous avez un contrôle indirect du centre
donc qui joue une partie ou en fait qui
garde tes pièces et je pense qu'il veut
garder des options de gagner quand même
tu vois là déjà c'est un peu
mais on va récupérer à 7 c'est
l'objectif je pense de fait d'obs ici
[Musique]
oui on pouvait la mettre peut-être
faut faire gaffe quand même parce que
faut prendre un 4
ça mettra une pression sur Carolie F3 et
en cas d'échange on peut avoir ces
quatre en l'air
pour l'instant on a 4 scène en tête avec
fedo seguieff et des joueurs qui sont
devant nous là qui ont tous les deux
cinq et demi sur 6 suivi par habshotov
Champion du monde en titre qui lui a 5
sur 6 et après une une quinzaine de
jours à 4h30 bon beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs comme erikasi Sarine guéri van
forest union libre des pots bref
beaucoup beaucoup de monde ça va un peu
ce
décanter dans les à venir mais donc là
vous savez donc on est au deuxième jour
du tournoi rapide demain le dénouement
toujours pareil on se retrouvera tous
les jours donc là ça a démarré à 10
heures demain on a vu que c'était encore
10 heures
et ensuite j’enchaîneront avec le Blitz
il y a bien
titres qui sont décernés bien sûr
championnats du monde de rapides
champion du monde de rapides et champion
du monde de Blitz
à moitié la 4 / 6 comme un
embuscade comme il s'est planqué quand
même Gaëlle
et carreaux
assez forts
c'est pas si facile de ne pas perdre
quoi donc faut faire gaffe à chaque fois
il sait que ses adversaires sont sont
dangereux
tu voudrais le doubler de Maxime en
blitz ok parce qu'en rapide là c'est
déjà un petit peu dur
après Carsan il est pas l'abri par une
partie un jour et puis ça peut aller
très vite hein on va voir un peu ce qui
se passe dans tous les cas je vois qu'il
y a déjà eu la défaite de Niall Sarine
contre du bof est-ce que tu peux juste
nous montrer ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'est très expéditif quand même ou
le match
j'avais 12-13 ans je l'avais placé ce
matin 18 coups pour Niall Sarine avoir
un petit peu partenaire de club qui n'a
pas réussi à
un survivre avec son grand bidame
accepté regardez la belle tour le Rook
lift qui a été employé par par Dubois
dommage ça qui perdue regardez bien je
vous la
Smati
il faudra l'analyser celle-là
une tour qui est passée de A à H4 et qui
a permis le sacrifice de dames avec
magnifique
en fait comprenez pas pour moi c'est
important qu'on n'est pas gagnant
et du coup la partie 3 4 5 3 4 5 ok bon
voilà l'évaluation du module qui est
ce qu'elle est ça paraissait pas si
simple quand même cette position on
préfère le fou dans cette position là je
pense que le problème vient du fait que
A5 et sans doute vraiment faiblard avec
parfait qui peut être faible parce que
ben j'ai quand même une majorité de mon
côté aussi que les Noirs donc du coup tu
vois si le pion était à 6 je pense que
la position serait plus égale voir
évidemment
vous perdez votre cavalier donc là il va
reculer à boussatorov
intelligent parce que il y a beaucoup de
problèmes après être rangés frangin je
peux déjà prendre en H4 si j'ai envie et
d'avoir une finale supérieure donc il ne
jouera pas ça
attention à tous ces cinq peut-être
et oui c'est jouer d'ailleurs voilà et
il y a du jeu avec le cavalier mais le
pion à 5 s'il tombe ça fera un 3 contre
1 à l'aide dame accompagné par le fou
alors je pense qu'il veut se venger
comme ça exactement
sur ton front à ça je dois retourner
deux bah c'est la partie avec toi la
partie et peut-être
intermédiaire voilà c'était le coup
logique
est-ce qu'on intercale tous ces cinq
échecs pour pas éviter un B6 voilà il y
a état des risques de B6 3b7 il fallait
vérifier encore parce qu'il y avait des
tourbé 5 mais c'était dangereux très
dangereux il y a des cahiers des cartes
c'était très dur à calculer
les pièces sont un peu en fait mais
et
laisser passer l'orage juste avec ton
géant je croise tout pour ma tour elle
est quand même intéressante pour
contrôler le pion C2 qui est pas
d'embrouille après je vais pouvoir me
concentrer peut-être sur le reste
comment je peux gérer mon histoire de
pion G2 là
après le roi il est dans les courants
d'air quand même est-ce que tu peux
vraiment me prendre en fait sauf ouais
tu vas te prendre le 6
que je vois le tour des chèques pour
essayer d'embêter stouffe est-ce que
j'ai le droit de faire fouter 6 tout va
être tours et 7 et chaque ouais c'est
quand même pas simple pour les noirs
[Musique]
mais attention que la moindre précision
ben tu vois j'ai un peu aussi faut pas
se tromper on a chacun Usain Bolt trois
champions à 5 moi c'est mon pion à 4
sérieux pour ne pas ici
qui a pris une option il a pris une
option il joue vraiment clairement pour
le gars et il y a deux façons pour de
Saint-Orens dans ce type de position de
jouer soit très passif soit chercher du
contre-jeu et on voit qu'il est dans le
contre-jeu hein forcément parce que les
défenses passives faut pas avoir de
retard matériel c'est vraiment ce qu'on
a une position de soumission avec
l'égalité matérielle là c'est pas le cas
il a du retard matériel il cherche les
complications dans ce cas-là pour ne pas
pour ne pas perdre il veut ouais
aller dans le Bronx pour que le gain
soit moins évident pour l'adversaire
et mvl
[Musique]
avec une position
du mal à comprendre un posteriori le
choix de Maxime ce que là il est en
train de
jouer une partie un peu soporifique
ou les chances de gains sont extrêmement
limitées bon vraisemblablement pour les
deux joueurs et ça va passer
on avait annoncé une partie de combat on
a eu tout l'inverse
on le voit bien et non mais moi je suis
un peu déçu parce que
là on voit les ambitions de Maxime au
final
qui sont pas enfin tu vois c'est que
c'est pas de gagner contre contre
Sébastien Mazet
on trouve bien sûr que Sébastien un
joueur brillant mais Maxime il est
obligé de jouer ce genre de position
il doit essayer de battre il doit
essayer de battre de Sébastien quoi si
enfin en tout cas s'ils veulent le
champion du monde quoi aussi il veut
faire si il veut faire
un podium quand mais a priori c'était
pas son idée je vois que c'est Richard
importe
je vais contre une image
je pense que tu as dû gagner
e
un peu énervé on peut aller voir si tu
veux cette partie en vrai à la partie
bien sûr la partie entre Seb
mais évidemment les rois
du gagner la partie que s'est-il passé
je vais voir rapidement
on va vite vitesse de l'éclair
juste pour voir
c'est normal
j'ai l'impression qu'il a fait parce que
la position pour l'instant nous prêtait
pas trop de
ça va pas du tout
sur son H4
après précédemment sur sur ah oui oui il
y a toute une séquence
si je joue HK directement
avec l'idée puissantes
pourquoi
la différence
c'est magnifique grosse
erreur de calcul de Richard rapporte
après vous voyez on voit pas facilement
les choses
il est en train de revenir complètement
ok incroyable vous avez compris un
histoire c'était pas simple mais quand
il a joué dans ma huit Richard apporte
il voulait valoriser son Pione il a raté
le H4 mais il a raté le D4 intermédiaire
terrible qui est donc grosse gaffe de la
part de rapport qui perd contre lui-même
je pourrais avoir rapidement Moussard
quand même voir Jules
faire parce qu'il a un pion il est
vraiment dans une position à deux
résultats puis on passait qui est très
très bien ici il a un monstre donc
extrêmement difficile à jouer
le fouet qui est mal placé et les pièces
blanches qui sont beaucoup très très
agréable à jouer cette position cette
partie qui va être je pense gagner par
deux résultats
il va revenir dans le tournoi
espérons-le
bon et Magnus peut-être parce que bien
sûr la partie entre les deux Français ça
tourne en rond ouais ça donne pas trop
envie de suivre cette partie je suis
désolé mais il se passe vraiment
vraiment rien
on verra peut-être dans le dans l'ultra
Zino
mais bon même si même sibastien ici il a
10 secondes je vois pas comment il sera
arnaquer quoi
peu de temps il y a toujours moyen mais
bon c'est vrai que là c'est c'est les
perspectives assez modeste on a bien
d'accord avec ce tour pour vous dire que
la nul pour être signé donc vraiment pas
longtemps
et puis on sait que plus faible ben
viens le chercher
donc c'est pas si simple
mon son te semble bien faible en tout
cas Charlie tu me regardes le choix
d'ouverture de mvl ressemble au choix
tactique de Dédé des champs bonne
stratégie pour être champion du monde
aux échecs quand vous jouez une petite
équipe ça marche pareil au foot vous
allez me dire il faut il faut y aller et
là en fait ce qui est bizarre c'est que
la mvl la gare et le bus
et normalement c'était le favori malgré
la
le fait qu'il n'est pas la couleur c'est
à dire que c'est Sébastien qui avait les
blancs
en fait lui bouge pas parce que lui il
sera en prise lui il sera plus prenable
par le roi ok là c'est conjointe c'est
ouais je pense que la proportionnel va
être
bien oui je pense que c'est le contexte
affectif qui a amené cette cette partie
qui était pas très rigolote à suivre
dans le sens où je pense que les deux
joueurs n'avaient pas trop envie d'aller
chercher quoi
ouais bon après c'est quand même plutôt
un Maxime d'aller chercher
un bon bah c'est quand même dans les
deux c'est le moins fort des deux et
puis donc bon bah c'est toi Maxime
d'aller de dire allez viens me chercher
quoi
ouais kiki je pense qu'il y aura pas de
de différents significations dans le jeu
de mvl suite au changement de coach
aussi rapidement
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur ce
sujet avec tout c'est que on verrait
peut-être d'être différent
particulièrement dans la préparation à
terme préparation d'ouverture ça c'est
ce qui sera le plus facile à avoir s'il
y a des changements
et sinon sur le style Maxime de toute
façon maintenant c'est un joueur qui a
été formé ne changera plus ça sera quand
même une bête de calcul
après comme n'importe quel joueur dans
n'importe quel domaine il peut encore
progresser
particulièrement sur les points
améliorés quoi c'est à dire que sur le
calcul c'est quand même peut-être
le meilleur joueur du monde ou vraiment
là il va rentrer dans le top 5 tout le
temps de des gens cités
après sur ces préparations d'ouverture
on verra
pendant longtemps maxime a été décrié
pour non pas ses ouvertures mais sa
souplesse dans le répertoire d'ouverture
et ce qui m'intéresse moi en tant que
que suiveur admirateur c'est de voir
si on dans sa nouvelle équipe de
préparation on lui proposera des
contenus différents en termes
d'ouverture parce que je constate que la
plupart des joueurs modernes de très
haut niveau
ont des répertoires souples
veulent ne pas montrer à l'adversaire ce
qu'ils vont jouer à l'avance or chez
Maxime c'est tout l'inverse et ce qui
peut passer chez des grands maîtres dans
des Open de monsieur tout le monde ne
passe pas au niveau c'est même si Maxime
il a une mémoire quasiment infaillible
et joue des joueurs qui ont aussi les
mêmes caractéristiques donc donner à
l'avance et dire à l'avance à ses
adversaires ce qu'il allait jouer c'est
quand même très très difficile à
comprendre
Maxime tu es quand même très très
visible dans ces ouvertures
on est tous d'accord en fait sur ce
sujet là
c'était très dur donc du coup là il faut
qu'il change un petit peu et qu'il est
qu'il soit plus tu vois moi prévisible
et un peu mieux préparé quoi mais
préparez non parce qu'il est quand même
très bien préparé
mais c'est vrai en fait que voilà quoi
tu vois on l'a
complètement je partage Blade avia
partage aussi
et c'était une question un petit peu
tabou à moi parce que Maxime on avait
marre de cette question
bah ouais parce que tout le monde mais
en même temps en tant que coach et bien
sûr sauf je coach des joueurs
qui n'ont pas le talent de Maxime parce
que Maxime c'est un talent à part c'est
un joueur à part parce que maintenant
c'est on parle plus d'un petit jeune on
parle vraiment d'un adulte qui a été
formé qui au-delà d'être un
joueur hyper précoce et à confirmer cela
et devenu un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde maintenant
c'était incompréhensible pour le grand
public mais pour les spécialistes aussi
donc
[Musique]
ça c'est alors après il disait qu'il y a
beaucoup de travail engagés pour changer
d'ouverture mais je pense que tous les
jours de niveau sont confrontés à cela
et il disait qu'il y avait une
différence changer d'ouverture et la
connaître un peu et la jouer contre
Carlson quoi et ça je comprends mais bon
Kevin je suis agréablement surpris enfin
surpris et même
oui je suis très content en fait la
partie tournure qui a pris la partie de
nepomatique en train de totorov et je
vais de ce pas
ah merde j'avais la bonne caméra je suis
désolé désolé pour la pour la scène qui
change je vous montre du coup la
[Musique]
position de de amsterov qui a une
qualité d'avance contre une époque
natchi donc je rappelle par rapport à
par rapport à notre parc respectifs
moi je suis assez content de voir que
Abdou santorov on vient de me faire mal
mais de joueurs en plus je l'ai aussi
mis t'inquiète ouais mais quand même moi
je l'ai mis 2e donc elle est en train de
me faire mal
qui a perdu avant c'est vrai mais là il
me met deux buts à mes joueurs
qu'est-ce qui se passe là mais est-ce
que tu peux me montrer comment ça s'est
passé parce que tout à l'heure on s'est
quitté il y a 10 coups avec une position
légèrement avantage
pour des six à 5 qui perd direct
pourquoi
fermer le four alors regardez à 5 qui
perd un coup parce que après faut B6 il
y a le tour prend B6 avec une enfilade
ici qui a été raté complètement par
dépromératives incroyable
[Musique]
ah ouais ça ce niveau là c'est c'est dur
après tu vois encore une fois là on voit
des joueurs qui sont pas des ordis qui
sont des humains et qui font des gaffes
comme nous bien sûr
pour toi mais ma chérie si tu veux là on
peut dire que c'est à peu près une
tactique en deux coups mais bon pour un
joueur comme lui c'est
normal et là si tu veux il a vraiment
une chance pure alors je suis une bonne
foi c'est parce que j'explique juste
on provoque la réussite imaginons ils
défend pendant 40 coups et le mec se
craque là les pots il avait du temps
autant et il a oublié quelque chose et
c'est ce qu'on dit il y a pas de chance
aux échecs sur le long terme mais on
peut avoir de la chance dans une partie
et on peut évidemment les meilleurs
joueurs ont plus de chances que les
autres parce que il provoque la chance
ça c'est ces bateaux c'est la base
exactement raisonnable il dit que
c'était pas difficile comme tactique et
on lui fait confiance que c'est un
spécialiste tactique raisonne
et non c'est pas dur c'était pas dur ça
c'est facile et donc
là c'est archi gagnant et
va filer le pion F5 il va filer au bout
du monde est-ce qu'on irait pas voir la
partie on voit que Jul a gagné alors
Jules c'est bien il se refait au moins
il avait quand même un super avantage on
s'est arrêté à à gagner ces quatre là il
a mangé le pion C6 il a défendu il a mis
la tour il a eu un sacrifice de qualité
pensant que fou c'est 5 pouvait venir
manger la tour mais après échec
dans mes fut abondants très très sympa
dans les filtres regardez s'il vous
prend un F8 il y a tout reprend B2
j'enlève le clouage du Fou sur le sur le
roi et si roi je mange ici donc bon les
Noirs
juste après avoir perdu une partie de
manière un petit peu immonde il fallait
se refaire et la réussite il a réussi
cela et puis voilà il faudra en faire
deux trois comme ça pour pour pouvoir se
remettre dans le droit chemin et pouvoir
revenir sur la tête parce que tous les
joueurs de tête vont s'affronter il y
aura des nuls il y en a qui vont laisser
des plumes
du coup et ça peut être intéressant il
annule a été signé chez Sébastien Mazet
et mvl très prévisible depuis le
deuxième coup
on attendait on attendait la partie avec
impatience mais vraiment c'était sans
intérêt
je
[Musique]
suis déçu cette partie je ferai pas de
commentaire
là-dessus non non
est-ce qu'il va réussir à faire mieux
pour améliorer cette position il faut
que mon fou arrive en H4 tu es obligé
d'être le front H4 puisque le roi blanc
peut pas sortir je peux presque le
prendre quand ils vont H4 non
ça fait nul mais sur un foie H4 il faut
prendre je suis pas obligé bien sûr mais
je crois que ça marche
mais juste en fait
alors il est 5h de
5 heures de plus que chez nous Gilgamesh
Kazakhstan
voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on doit se lever le
soulever tôt et on vous encourage à
venir avec nous dès dès le début du
stream c'est à dire à 10h du matin en
général et le dernier jour à 9 heures du
matin
c'est en se levant tôt qu'on progresse
aux échecs je crois qu'on dit ça
[Rires]
salut thé vert connais pas salut thé
vert salut c'est soft je l'ai vu aussi
donc
et du coup alors j'ai pas pu suivre
j'étais en famille hier et était vert
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a pensé des
parties des parties de haut niveau
hier
est-ce qu'il t'a régalé un petit peu
tout et comment s'est passé votre stream
salut à tous
et bonjour à tous les à tous les
nouveaux tous les arrivants
donc ce qu'on va se passer à une
victoire de d'hab tout en physique sur
sur dépôt Abdou qui a déjà cartienne
alors thé vert il me dit dans le chat
stouf que tu as fait un cours de 7
heures il est ravi j'ai l'impression
d'ailleurs il y a eu aussi une partie de
ouf c'était
MVR harcha l'Indien il y a eu deux
belles parties comme ça vous a eu
d'autres c'est parti qui m'ont le plus
marqué moi c'est vrai que d'habitude on
est gâté et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on
attend notre gâté
parce que là on reste un peu sur notre
fin
contre l'Indien la partie de mvl il a
sacrifié deux tours et un cavalier
j'ai vu dans le dans le classement là je
vois enfin dans le dans les parties je
vois que Erika ici a battu guéri
on doit dire ce que ça fait plaisir ça
me fait plaisir pour mon entendeur de
club mais et aussi pour mon petit mais
ça me fait mal pour ton pari non mais en
vrai je suis pas malheureux
bien sûr
des fois pas sous-estimer mais tu vois
enfin je sais pas
ça qui me dégoûte c'est que il a
vraiment il avait vraiment fait le taf
visiblement sur cette partie et la
donnée la partie quand même de manière
un peu bébête
il était en avance autant et tout ça
quoi punaise après dépôts et des
capables de tout tu vois malheureusement
c'est un joueur qui est génial mais il
fait des craquages
bêtement parce que bon c'est un super
joueur mais
parce que c'est même un génie des échecs
pur et en fait il a quand même
ouais il joue hyper vite et des fois il
déconne c'est ça ce que veut dire
souffre mais après mais c'est des
remarques qu'on fait à des joueurs qui
ont moins de 12 ans dans un cheval
régional quoi ce que tu es en train de
dire donc c'est hallucinant que pour un
joueur de cette classe là personne n'est
réussi encore à lui dire bah c'est très
bien ce que tu fais parce qu'il met la
pression donc il en gagne aussi sauf
s'il ne le ferait pas il gagne en
mettant la pression au joueur mais c'est
bizarre qui régule pas ça quoi en fait
en fait ce que je veux dire avec tout ça
c'est que si tu veux le fait de jouer
vite comme ça c'est au final quand même
son sa manière d'être tu vois il met
vachement impression sur les joueurs à
chaque fois en jouant vite et que c'est
hyper bien je sais pas le faire en plus
mais
c'est son style donc là son style si tu
veux lui fait défaut il perd la partie à
cause de son style mais combien on a
gagné tu vois c'est ça et en fait ça
fait partie de son style bah écoute tu
vas lui dire
parfaitement les choses parce que
en fait
mon capitaine d'équipe en top en Top 16
c'est Jean-Noël rive qui est grand
maître français alsacien et qui est un
peu cette caractéristique là mais bon
par rapport à un époque c'est si mais
énormément la pression et comme les pots
il va être brillant par moment et ça va
le desservir à d'autres moments mais
plutôt pro de l'entraînement
ils n'ont quand même pas le même c'est
un grand maître donc il est très
talentueux mais il a pas le même talent
que connais pas et une épaule
normalement il a une équipe qui le suit
et tout ça quoi oui c'est plus beau j'ai
du mal à comprendre tu vois sauf que
personne n'est réussi à le
dompter sur ce côté là quoi est-ce que
moi je suis un peu comme ça aussi je je
il y a plein de parties où je joue quand
même très vite et plein de fois des
couettes tempo et ça m'arrive en tournoi
de faire des fois je fais des grosses
gaffes tu vois en un coup des trucs que
tu ferais jamais tu vois mais
ça m'est déjà arrivé enfin ça m'arrive
souvent de faire des grosses gaffes
comme ça parce que ben je suis un petit
peu sous le feu de l'action et je suis
un peu
tu vois
de la presse c'est le risque un des
joueurs qui mène la presse tu fais un
oubli quoi c'est ça
trop en contrôle parce que effectivement
quand tu le dis pour ma part je suis
plutôt un joueur qui essaie de garder le
contrôle mais je vais aussi me [ __ ]
mal autant donc au final c'est un peu
l'entre-deux qu'il faudrait trouver quoi
sauf c'est ça un entre deux on pourrait
être fort on pourrait être fort parce
que moi moi
par contre quand on chante avec notes et
ben souvent je panique parce que
vous êtes note je panique alors pourtant
quand je suis en blitz et ben je suis
habitué et même des bullets je suis
habitué de jouer avec peu de temps la
pendule mais quand je suis en partie
officiel j'ai plus de temps c'est
bizarre mais j'ai pas mes moyens enfin
c'est assez bizarre ce que je te dis tu
vois là
je comprends tout à fait parce que on en
discutait récemment je sais plus à
quelle occasion mais quand tu es
ambulette tu peux remarcher c'est pas
grave etc quand tu toujours toute ta
partie de tes 5 heures de travail sur
une partie longue sur quelques coups
jouer rapidement donc un coup de dés bah
alors là ça peut ça peut vite mal se
passer quoi tu es tu es vert tu pourras
pas refaire tu pourras pas défaire ce
que tu as fait c'est terminé
donc le stress n'est pas le même quoi
donc c'est assez légitime que tu es pas
les mêmes sensations puis c'est dur sauf
je trouve de passer au mode tu es en
mode lent mode rapide et mode Blitz
c'est mode Bullet quoi dans la même
partie quoi c'est pas possible quoi
c'est clair c'est clair mais non non en
tout cas en tout cas
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre même tu as
même des très très bons joueurs de Blitz
qui des fois on
a des problèmes en direct et tous ça
veut rien dire en fait bien sûr c'est
bon en tout castroff qui qui
n'est pas tranquille une fois que c'est
joué tourbé voilà tourbé un jour
qui nous ont fait la petite blague qui
sortent mais ça a pas été relevé par par
Kevin j'ai pas entendu j'ai pas entendu
j'ai entendu mais j'ai pas j'ai pas
prêté attention malheureusement il avait
pas la référence
c'est pas drôle maintenant si on répète
une blague
ça dépend ça peut ça peut être un jeu de
mots ça peut être ça peut être pas mal
de choses
mais en fait tu me parlais du fait que
si tu joues si tu gafs sur une partie
alors que tu étais en fin tu vois tu
étais tout la partie tu étais gagnant
gagnant-gagnant etc et là et là tu pars
en blitz et quand tu gares et ben thé
vert tu vois et quand
sérieusement à la question tu vois et du
coup il faut suivre attention que
français 5 il y a un mat désolé
mais il est toujours ouverte de toute
façon t'inquiète pas il change pas même
quoi qu'il est pas menti il est quand
même
tu arrives toujours au bon moment mais
là c'est vrai que c'était c'était un des
meilleurs moments du stream pour
l'instant
[Rires]
c'est énorme c'est
comme les highlights mais en direct
c'est un nouveau concept en fait c'est
incroyable
abandon abandon de abandon de dépôt
tu as mérité peut-être pas mérité pas
mérité complètement
c'est toujours pareil en fait il avait
fait une bonne partie mais comme il fait
une gaffe en un couple elle est
complètement raté ça le haut niveau
alors on peut on peut la montrer la
gaffe si vous voulez avant camping ne
repartent c'était une partie
au passage voilà partie durement menée
par par un dépôt qui a un pion net
d'avance ici et une position Ben qui qui
se travaille mais bon tu vois on va
juste retour ces cartes et après c'est
voilà et il a joué à 5 pour mettre
mais il se prend tour à 8 il oublie
qu'il y avait une petite enfilade après
d'ailleurs
pour expliquer comment un joueur de haut
niveau gaffe et il a pas trouvé une peau
fin il a oublié parce que le roi vient
d'arriver en C1 et en plus Roissy il le
joue donc c'est un nouveau motif que les
deux pièces soient alignées sur la
première rangée et en plus trois séances
c'est un coup d'agression donc il est
pas du tout en train de surveiller les
possibilités de l'adversaire et après la
joie un coup naturel de stratégie A5
pour avancer sa majorité de pions et le
motif n'était pas présent puisque le roi
était en B2 donc voilà
[Musique]
tout à fait raison un manque de
vérification c'est le bon jargon bien
d'accord
il s'est fait rectifier
et Robinson nous dit que mvlenakan
décolle pas mvl a bien bloqué cette
bloqué il a bloqué
il a garé le bus MV la Garenne le bus
contre Sébastien
l'ouverture déjà surprenante et puis en
fait il a jamais essayé de faire quoi
que ce soit donc bah décevant
surprenant décevant exactement
[Musique]
qui va enlever les pièces à la place de
dépôt c'est l'arbitre qui va venir les
ranger tout à l'heure il y a pas de
système de qualification le machin c'est
c'est finalement mon nombre de points
réalisés dans le tournoi donc évidemment
il faut essayer d'en faire le maximum
mais là quand même VL
veut gagner le tournoi en tout cas elle
est venu pour ça parce que on rappelle
là c'est le cheval du monde de rapides
et je prends du monde de Blitz l'an
passé
c'est un demi point de perdu là par un
demi point de gagner dans la situation
puis il a pas vraiment joué
pour essayer de déconcer son adversaire
donc Sébastien c'est un peu dommage
quand on voit l'écart de niveau sur le
papier qui ne tente pas quelque chose
même avec les Noirs après il y a la
factif il se connaissent très bien et on
peut comprendre dans
pourquoi pourquoi ça s'est passé bon et
Vincent Kemer va faire énormément
souffrir
you dans cette position je pense qu'il
gagnera d'ailleurs avec le noir
ici c'est dur de trouver des CROUS tout
fin pour les blancs c'est pas facile il
faut attendre il faut savoir attendre
et même pour les Noirs c'est pas c'est
simple de gagner ça encore
parce que souvent qui peuvent arriver de
partout
et c'est pas simple encore une pour
gagner ça
est-ce que justement c'est pas parce que
très bien
contre contre ventes forest qui sont en
train de se préparateur ben il a joué il
a gagné en fait il y a quand même une
grosse différence de niveau entre les
deux
et en plus un tournoi de rapide enfin
mvl doit tenter dire
là il est quand même tu vois c'est pas
comme si les deux joueurs étaient
proches en élo il y a quand même 200
points d'écart
mvl doit tenter tous les jours de gagner
cette partie
alors il y a une question de route qui
dit ce serait pas plus sympa une petite
phase finale avec les quatre ou huit
premiers
et pourquoi pas pour pour essayer
d'intéresser le format après si on fait
ça le système de qualification bon
faudrait faire un peu moins de ronde et
toujours un peu bâtard parce que
finalement
c'est celui des fois qui finit huitième
enfin enfin qui peut se réveiller dans
la phase de finale et gagner là
franchement ce type là c'est très juste
aussi ce type de format tu vois ça
favorise également
regarde exemple tout bête on a commandé
tous les deux les championnats du monde
de fiche à random et tu vois que
il a complètement écrasé le tournoi il
avait 8 sur 8 et avant dans les phases
de poules il est arrivé après il est
sorti des poules et il s'est fait
éliminer par Naka puis conte Carlsen
pour la troisième place
et donc il a fini au final troisième
quatrième pardon alors qu'il avait 8 sur
8 au début alors que ça ne serait pas
forcément passé s'il y avait eu un
format différent tu vois donc moi je
suis tu vois enfin tu mérites quand même
ça dépend vraiment de de de
du format après mais moi je suis pour tu
vois là le mec qui fait le temps en tête
et ben il va gagner le temps quoi tu
vois attention tu peux arriver avec un
départage dégueulasse tu as fait un
tournoi tout en bas tu as gagné quatre
ans à la fin et boum tu arrives à te
rapprocher du du peloton et finalement
éliminer les joueurs à gagner quoi je
trouve que c'est pas forcément si juste
que ça tu vois de te laisser une chance
d'être champion du monde alors que tu es
arrivé 8e quoi tu vois c'est mon point
de vue après chacun son point de vue
salut François et pour répondre aussi à
l'hommage du 92 et ben écoute je ne
connais pas du tout David figorito ouais
ça me dit quelque chose j'ai déjà vu
dans le chasse basse commenter des
parties etc par contre je connais pas
mais le match ça dépend de ton niveau
franchement
tu devrais nous mettre ton niveau dans
le chat mais sans parler du livre en
lui-même n'achetez pas de bouquin sur
les ouvertures sauf si vous avez déjà un
très très bon niveau mais des livres
spécifiques sur la nage d'or qui est
l'ouverture peut-être la plus complexe
aux échecs sur 4
pour vraiment avoir un très joli niveau
au moins 1800 je pense pour jouer et
essayer de jouer à nashdorf mais je
pense que ce serait mieux à partir de
2000 c'est que mon avis
mais je trouve que c'est dur
je suis entièrement d'accord avec toi
surtout la nage d'orf vraiment
il faut avoir un livre en tant que 2100
ok c'était 2100 oui ça va là tu peux tu
peux tu peux largement après ça sera du
temps quand même
si tu attends infini pour faire des
échecs ou pas tant fini c'est aussi
notre donnée c'était actif dans la vie
ou c'était ou cité ou si tu es étudiant
ou si tu es encore plus jeune et que tu
attends illimité pour les échecs c'est
plus facile quoi c'est ça mais donc là
on peut pas de répondre tu vois
après il faut il faut travailler combien
de fois les gens achètent des livres
sans les lire
j'en fais partie
[Musique]
210000 déjà c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose donc est-ce que tu es un
joueur de club le match ou pas du tout
c'est pas du film
mais oui
internet sur tous les sites sont quand
même plutôt plutôt sympathiques
tout fait moi ben on a à peu près le
même niveau sur le chasse Scrum enfin
moi je suis à 26 26 50 de moyen les 26
50 toi Stéphane je fais pas exactement
ta moyenne ça doit être assez proche ou
peut-être un petit peu au dessus
du coup c'est pas que ça veut rien dire
mais
bon imaginons qu'on est après le même
niveau qu'en l'an bah on est quand même
surévalué de 200 points par rapport à
moi mon classement
c'est plus de 100 sauf c'est plus 300 à
peu près
c'est pas vraiment pareil mais oui on
est surclassé nous
mais
c'est pour beaucoup de joueurs c'est
comme ça
donc avoir mais après souvent en fait je
pense que le pire c'est le débutant
quand vous êtes débutant il y a beaucoup
de monde qui pensent que lire un bouquin
faire une ouverture je sais pas quoi ça
va vous faire gagner les parties ça va
progresser aux échec
là c'est une grosse erreur vous savez
que les ouvertures c'est vraiment quand
on a un bon niveau on commence à aller
bosser et 2100 en club c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus normal
mais débutant par exemple je sais pas si
vous avez 1000 800 900 ou même 1100 1200
les ouvertures on peut avoir une base et
avoir et travailler un truc tranquille
etc
pour avoir un schéma solide mais
travailler pour un planage d'or fin 1200
hello ou même
10056 moi je trouve que c'est pas
intéressant E3 gagne la partie joli coup
de Vincent Kemer et le Pione va filer en
cas de prise et surprise tout mais
surtout ressemble on doit pouvoir me
faire droit des trois on est sur F3 j'ai
découvertes
des découvertes de partout la roi des
trois gagne par exemple tranquille au
roi des trois c'est vraiment le gain
très très efficace
3 ça marche aussi
c'est encore plus facile F3
il y aura pas de finale il y a souvent
c'est vraiment donc très seronde on en a
vu 5 hier 4 aujourd'hui 4 demain et au
meilleur des 13 ondes il y aura
le champion du monde de rapides en mix
lien bien sûr une catégorie dont on n'a
pas trop parlé effectivement c'est la
catégorie des féminines stouf est-ce que
vous en avez parlé avec thé vert hier
parce qu'on nous a fait un petit
question un petit appel du pied par
rapport à cela pas du tout pour vous
pour vous dire la vérité on m'a enfin
moi je dois m'occuper du du
mixte donc j'ai j'ai même pas regardé
pour pour vous dire la vérité
mais voilà vous avez les résultats sur
le sur le site officiel qui met le lien
sur le chat mais j'ai pas eu tout
regardé à ce niveau là au niveau des des
tours féminins
ah ouais manque de représentants en
France
parce que j'ai vu que Pauline Pauline
elle joue un tournoi déjà
nous sur le fr pas de représentants plus
le côté
le côté aussi que les meilleurs joueurs
du monde bah c'est une compétition mixte
donc les les jeunes femmes qui
représentaient les conditions pouvaient
aussi participer
c'est normal qu'on commente l'événement
majeur quoi voilà
moi je trouve ça normal en tout cas et
après je trouverai pas normal non plus
que que les meilleurs jeunes femmes qui
maîtrisent qui qui ont toutes les
conditions requises pour le faire ben il
y a aussi quoi Stéphane ça peut être ça
aussi hein
comme on a vu ou pas quand elle jouait
beaucoup
elle y allait quoi
alors là d'ailleurs neiman ils viennent
gagner sa partie donc Imane il se
rapproche un petit peu de c'était la
grosse cote de jouer
on n'avait pas fait
je pense il a eu un début quand même de
tournois assez compliqué quand même
bon là il a quand même pas mal commencé
la partie on sait pas encore ce que ça
va nous donner
attends je vais mettre le micro
vous ayez un peu la caméra de la salle
peut-être qu'on va pouvoir voir des
parties donc là on a en direct on a le
point de mine contre ma Médoc donc le
tournoi de mine c'est un habitué de tous
les les tailles de Tuesday tous les
tournois que vous pouvez avoir c'est
c'est un monstre du circuit qui est qui
est encore enfin tu viens de passer à
peine à peine grand maître il y a
quelques mois
mais qui est sur tous les sites 3200 et
d'autres partout c'est c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs Internet le tournoi
qui vient ici de
perdre je pense contre enfin nul contre
ma méthode
ça joue encore ça joue encore
[Musique]
roi F6 c'était le coup pour jouer pour
gagner pour moi médorf pour l'ordi nul
mais des tours qui peuvent arriver il y
a des pions qui avancent là c'est
extrêmement dur à tenir ça prend les
blancs quand même
oui le roi qui sert à rien
il y a même le roi qui peut mettre mate
si je bouge mon roi tu vois des fois il
y a des là vous avez pas de seconde
enfin très peu de temps
et pour le Torx pour te répondre je
crois que c'est Willy fan qui doit avoir
un classement proche de 26-50 26 40 la
première joueuse mais elle est beaucoup
moins active que par le passé
dans un moment donné et puis en fait
elle a pris la priorité à ses études
plus tôt que les chèques
et donc donc c'est ça on n'a pas voulu
être professionnel des échecs et
est-ce que c'est passé
qui était
voilà
après peut-être simplement roi G7
mais oui
pour pour le mixte j'ai vu qu'il y avait
encore une partie chez les filles
malheureusement j'ai pas le temps que ça
c'est ça c'est vu des jeunes femmes dans
les tournois mixtes on a vu Alexandra
goriaskina qui est la meilleure joueuse
russe russe qui a récemment fait le
tournoi des candidates qui a joué des
tournois avec en mixte et dans les
années 90 il y a même une jeune femme
qui a qui détient le record et l'eau
c'est Judith Polgar qui était très très
connu à l'époque qui jouait les gros
tournois avec cast paraff qui est la
seule femme à avoir dépassé la barre
symbolique des 2700 et l'eau que que
je vais vous mettre la caméra sur les
filles
que ce soit une femme ou un homme qu'on
attend ce qu'à ce moment-là il y a pas
de pas véritablement de de
corrélation avec le sexe dans ces cas-là
c'est vraiment
plutôt
[Musique]
la qualité de jeu du joueur fort qui va
déterminer
qu'il réussit à gagner ou non donc là on
a une partie entre deux jeunes femmes
d'ailleurs à l'écran sauf que tu nous tu
nous régales de cette finale de file
d'or donc cette finale de tour qui est
qui est nul
parce que le pion cavalier c'est un des
plus mauvais pions à avoir et peut-être
le pion tour dans ce type de position
et le cavalier le pion cavalier permet
même une défense très passive donc même
si on connaît mal les finales théoriques
on peut faire nul quand même cette
finale donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment pas très intéressant là
ce qu'on voit
ça représente
pas beaucoup d'intérêt on va dire
la joueuse noire elle est obligée de
jouer parce que elle
elle ne peut que gagner mais en fait
elle n'a pas vraiment de de stratégie
pour gagner et puis la joueuse blanche
est en soumission et va attendre
attention de ne pas pousser le purge de
4 quand même voilà c'est normal
3 tour à 3 pour l'instant avec vous vous
avez pas les cases sur les fichiers
et oui
la souris
gardez les dons de voyance un petit peu
tu as vu ça se souffre regarde
les choses
voyance maintenant voilà bon bref ça
représente pas trop d'intérêt parce que
la position est bloquée c'est une sorte
de forteresse où il n'y a rien et la
joueuse blanche d'ailleurs va faire
peut-être nul on va voir
directement sur H2O
G4 est-ce que à votre avis on peut
manger la tour ça va être la question
est-ce qu'on a déjà on peut manger la
tour ou pas ah pardon j'ai cru que j'ai
trouvé en prison
à tout que
on ne croit pas
très bonne question pédagogique de tout
voilà qui vous fait travailler vous
voyez soyez attentifs parce que sinon
tout va vous piéger voilà pas mal elle
était belle celle-là j'ai bien aimé et
je pensais que c'était l'idée de vouloir
bon c'est l'introduction du mini guide
sur les finales de tours
mais si on avait pu si les tours étaient
sur la même rangée la question est-ce
qu'on aurait pu manger la tour bah la
réponse est oui parce qu'après on
reprend j'avais rager deux qui faisait
opposition
et ça va nul direct en fait en position
des fois il faut pas lui laisser se pain
béni à Néandertal et elle veut gagner
voilà ça fait répéter le son de tous les
coups
aucunement gagnable cette finale sauf
bien sûr à donner la tour en un mais tu
vois là elles sont en train de
s'accorder pour la nul voilà donc c'est
pas gagnable c'est complètement
complètement nul cette position
et c'est marrant que les filles aussi
ont des arbitres
filles aussi ta femme
qui arbitre les hommes
il y a moins de femmes aux échecs en
fait pour tout vous dire donc voilà
c'est
c'est quand c'est un peu comme au foot
maintenant on a Stéphanie Frappart en
France voilà
donc mais c'est vraiment moins courant
ouais du coup là bah écoutez
va y avoir une petite pause là de
tournoi je pense 5 10 minutes si vous
voulez enfin nous aussi 5 petites
minutes et on revient dans un instant je
peux vous laisser si vous voulez cette
cette caméra ce sera mieux que la que la
que la que la pub cheesecum comme ça au
moins vous voyez la salle de jeux vous
voyez les joueurs se promener et nous on
revient ma d'ici
quelques minutes voilà on vous laisse
avec la pub et on revient tout de suite
et on vous laisse aller voir nos chaînes
respectives nos sites respectives comme
d'habitude à chaque pause maintenant
voilà comme ça vous aurez toutes les
infos allez vous faire plaisir à tout de
suite on vous dit à tout de suite
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin
pour du coup la deuxième partie de la
journée enfin troisième partie mais là
on arrive à la moitié en fait du
deuxième volet de cette journée c'est ça
donc du coup pour la troisième ronde de
cette journée avec les apparements qui
viennent de sortir donc je peux vous les
donner si vous voulez dans l'ordre on a
4 scène du boeufs qui vont selon Carson
qui a 6 points
qui étaient rattrapé par fedo essaye
donc Carson noir et blanc contre duboff
tandis que Amsterdam je vois contre
Peter sayev on a 5 et demi on a Kemer et
erikasi et ensuite
il y a beaucoup de monde à 5 au don un
petit Niman qui joue contre McDo slow
donc partie intéressante on a aussi à
côté
Nakamura qui joue contre murzin le jeune
murzin le petit le petit russe pour mvl
mais il a les blancs contre par avion
par avion victime de Nakamura alors du
speechers Championship et on a du coup
un petit gris Mazet sympa et Jules et
ben il aura les Noirs contre team jingao
donc je ne le connais pas c'est un grand
maître de Singapour qui est
qui est
2462 hello donc plutôt un bon
apparemment pour Jules j'ai envie de
dire
on n'a pas du tout cité gris chouk dans
notre pari aussi ça pourrait être un
joueur qui remonte aussi
du monde de
Blitz et rapide donc greachu qui peut
clairement faire quelque chose dans ce
dans championnat quelque chose qui lui
tape le tableau 12 contre don chenko
et donc plein de petits aussi duels
intéressants comme sarenaduda un media
of petrociant la gare
donc plein de trucs intéressants en tout
cas ça va commencer dans quelques
instants là les joueurs font en train de
prendre place et oui malheureusement on
n'a pas le point d'exclamation standings
et à part te dire d'aller sur le site
pour avoir attendre non mais moi je vais
en fait mais le problème c'est que je
l'ai mais il faut que ce soit bien des
choses technicien non pas du tout ah bah
c'est des défis
je vous le montrer si vous voulez mais
en fait des fois ça m'a un peu de temps
à être mis à jour et du coup ben je peux
pas trop trop vous le montrer donc le
standing sont ici
je vais le laisser la question de qu'élu
93 stouf je chante tu as envie d'y
répondre je je vais voir ça pourquoi
l'inflation et l'eau s'est arrêtée
depuis quelques années moins de 2008 ils
sont plus qu'avant érosion du nombre de
2700 plus top 100 stable à 2150 et l'eau
depuis longtemps
déjà je me suis dit ça c'est une
question pour tout
je passe
elle était dur mon regard je pense que
vous statistique
après il y a pas vraiment de bon il y a
une inflation générale c'est clair de
mais après
après oui bon on aimerait bien en
profiter de la façon générale sauf ouais
moi j'ai pas profité
moi j'ai pas d'inflation ou alors je
regrette mais je monte en élo ce qui est
aussi possible
mais ouais non ça j'ai pas j'ai pas de
réponse mais
disons que les joueurs de l'élite se
font attraper par la nouvelle génération
ce qui pourrait expliquer une sorte
d'inflation pour toi qui n'en est pas
forcément une
après 45 il reste toujours à peu près à
50 points au dessus que les autres enfin
des autres donc après normal ça a pas
vraiment changé
voilà
je constate que je suis moins bien parti
que toi en termes de Paris
ouais du coup du coup on va revenir sur
notre notre petit maintenant ça je sais
pas on va revenir sur ça les petits
appareils peut-être pour qu'on vous
annonce et ça y est les joueurs sont en
train de s'installer donc la ronde 3 va
démarrer très prochainement
ok du coup voilà vous voyez là vous
voyez les joueurs la salle de jeux les
joueurs qui sont en train de s'installer
et qui est présent pour aller affronter
Magnus c'est ça donc du beauf qui qui
est qui est déjà assis moi j'ai les
caméras mais je vais donc Maxime qui
joue très très loin donc malheureusement
bah j'ai on a toujours pas la caméra de
Maxime Maxime qui joue je vais vous dire
qu'elle tape il joue
David parasian comme tu l'as dit et on
sait que sur ce type de cadence
paravient c'est un joueur dangereux pour
un Maxime qui n'a pas tant que ça de
points et j'ai vu que dans notre chat
que on nous annonçait que Sébastien
Mazet elle est affronter à Nice guéri
c'est ça donc tableau 10 Maxime table de
15 euh Sébastien et tape le 34 Jules
Jules qui a qui a 4 points qui est un
petit peu derrière pour l'instant il
faut qu'il gagne tout jusqu'à la fin
presque pour revenir parmi parmi les
premières tables c'est ça mission
quasiment impossible
c'est ça donc du coup bon on va voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe mais là
maintenant Maxime qui commence à marquer
des points parce que
s'il veut plus le choix il reste bon
hein tu vas me dire c'est encore quand
même pas mal de ronde mais il est quand
même il est quand même à un point et
demi derrière le groupe de tête Carson
tout ça donc rien que pour le départage
et tout ça et d'ailleurs le départage
est-ce que tu tu sais s'il y a des
règles spécifiques en cas d'égalité pour
le titre pour les 2e place il y aura un
départage que pour le les deux les deux
premiers
et du coup tu vois là je suis quand même
pas si mal quand on voit le classement
je suis dégoûté
et ben écoute il est il est 4e
nepo n'est pas
arrêtée
que j'avais eu 4e qui est qui est la
deuxième execo enfin premier execo en
fait donc je sais pas si mal que ça pour
l'instant toi tu as mis 47
tu as pas compris en embuscade en
embuscade souvent il y a des Snork qui
donne tout les deux premiers jours après
le troisième jour je rase normalement
c'est la fidélisation ça on appelle ça
j'espère quoi
une nouvelle pétrole
de Maxime qui cette fois-ci elle est
blanche il avait que le coca validé 3
qui a été utilisé dans le match de
championnat du monde de Carson contre
carvana le fameux cavalier 3 qui est pas
donné grand chose au final et donc donc
voilà maintenant il faut passer le
meilleur le mur de pierre
2600 vélo
c'est bizarre qu'il est pas quelque
chose d'un peu plus
un peu plus pétillant
qu'elle en est content
pour taper le pion des 5 sur le long
terme mais bon
on espère que là il va essayer quand
même de de certains il y a plus le choix
non
donc
[Musique]
au club déjà qui s'appelle les dragons
du tchesse pas mal comme nom original à
ah bah oui c'est pas mal
on a
on a plusieurs plusieurs clubs qui
rivalisent en France d'imagination
autour de leur nom
non ça va
donc encore une nul ben non non non non
comme ça mvl sinon contre mvl moi je
jouerai la pétrole aussi je peux te dire
que si je la joue la pétrole bah je peux
te dire qu'il va me secouer avant avant
que j'arrive à faire nul
non ok c'est une partie une partie mais
bon c'est vrai que c'est pas très
excitant tout ça à suivre dans
l'ouverture oui la structure vous voyez
elle est complètement symétrique donc
c'est des idées d'amélioration de pièces
assez fine et du coup c'est pas très
spectaculaire pour l'instant il va
falloir attendre la déséquilibre pour
que ça devienne spectaculaire mais en
même temps ça fait partie du jeu du jeu
stratégique écoutez c'est ça fait partie
de la vie du genre d'échec mais les
Noirs plutôt qu'essayer de trouver du
contre-jeu sont plutôt en train
d'essayer de vous bloquer
ce qui est prêt à jouer ça à la par
contre précédente c'est bien fait et ça
il se prend ça lui aussi qu'est-ce que
tu en penses c'est le jeu
alors on va voir un peu ce qui passe
chez les Français un jeu de Moussa qui
joue une pollution un peu plus
intéressante déjà
traditionnel on est sur
du Grand bidame refusé classique
pour le coup assiste qui a un coûtait
moderne a été joué qui peut permettre
des C5 pour la structure du pion isolé
voilà
en dessin
de le faire sinon on a un peu plus
coincé on peut aussi jouer des plans à
cavalier F8 cavalier G6 mais bon comme
un chi ça a été joué c'est moins vrai
la partie de guéri Mazet elle
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que c'est une
ressouriement avec un voyage 6 donc on
voulait souvent cavalier de banque avec
des morts mais cette position elle est
hyper vraiment F6 cavalier F7 c'est
voudrais du Black marlimmer aussi il
faut éviter du coup au tournoi et il
voudrait peut-être du Blackmar c'est ça
ouais c'est ça un peu abaisser la
barrelo pour voir du Blackmar
donc là
F7 c'est c'est le point normal de de
cette position et solide solide et ça
c'est intéressant donc moi je sors aussi
avec les Blancs j'aime bien prise je
suis tranquille donc les noirs
est un peu muselée par le Centre le
centre blanc la paire de fou qui est qui
est une
donc donc on va un petit peu comment
comment
Sébastien Lenoir s'en sort position donc
pendant ce temps je propose qu'on allait
voir un petit peu ben nos poulain
respectifs parce que bah les parties
pour l'instant sont pas très très
excitantes c'est que le début de la
ronde on peut aller voir ce qui se passe
près de chez Carlson car c'est un double
du coup qui est une partie importante
car celle qui est en tête du tournoi et
qui joue contre un joueur qui a un deuil
pour le moins que lui donc personne qui
joue P3 une personne qui joue P3 alors
hier
il l'ajout plusieurs fois déjà
et du coup bah écoute ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'on est typiquement dans une
structure qu'on pourrait trouver dans
l'espagnol d'échange avec un fou B5 qui
serait venu prendre en C6 et on a le 4
contre 3
ici donc potentiellement d'un côté là on
va pouvoir pousser les pions et faire
des menaces
mais comme il y a des pions doublés chez
les noirs et ben il a beaucoup de mal à
vraiment avancer par exemple tout à fait
voilà imaginons juste un truc bête après
B5 si jamais moi je toucherai un bon là
je gagne un pion évidemment mais je
parle de structure
si les Noirs un jour veulent essayer de
se créer un pion passé ils pourront pas
parce que la prise moi je mange sur un
Bion et au final vous voyez que les
pions C
sont bloqués par mon pioncer d'ailleurs
en fait il y a aucun moyen de se créer
pion passé dans cette structure là avec
les Noirs c'est quasiment trois contre
trois d'ailleurs de ce côté là aussi et
voilà et du coup
du coup d'ailleurs du bof et
entreprenant du mauvais côté pour lui
dans certains sens puis il essaye de
museler les quatre pions avec ces trois
pions
de l'échiquier si on a enlevé les
cavaliers les fous les tours et ben la
position serait quoi qu'on gagnante pour
les blancs
parce qu'en fait comme ici on a trois
contre quatre mais on dit que les pions
ici n'avancent pas et ben c'est un peu
comme si j'avais un plan de plus au
final
donc un but peut-être pour 45 il peut se
dire bon je change tout ça et puis il
peut gagner la finale de roi donc c'est
une stratégie en tout cas qui là
clairement en tête parce qu'il connaît
les structures d'option les deux
connaissent tout ça mais en tout cas
vous voyez que du bof va devoir garder
un petit peu des pièces pour pour
essayer de faire quelque chose en tout
cas du bord se retrouve dans une
position à deux résultats
soit il arrive à faire nul soit il
perdra ça serait très étonnant qu'il
battent Carlson dans une position comme
ça qui est absolument sans risque du
côté
du côté des blancs
la pollution ici elle est quand même
quasiment zéro chance
solides et des Noirs pas la colonne ils
ont une structure qui est moins bas etc
jouer pour le gain votre c'est comme ça
contre un joueur de ce niveau-là c'est
par contre si 45 gagne on peut assister
à une masterclasse positionnelle où vous
allez comprendre que on peut jouer que
sur un avantage unique de structures de
pions alors que il y en équilibre au
niveau de l'activité des pièces de la
sécurité du roi du rapport matériel bref
tout est égal à part cette avantage que
ce que vous a décrit en termes de
structure de pions
du coup jouer seulement là dessus c'est
les joueurs d'élite qui arrivent à le
faire voilà c'est le numéro un mondial
et on va voir s'il arrive à valoriser ce
4 contre 3 mais en tout cas toute la
partie c'est un véritable fil rouge il y
a un petit déséquilibre qu'il va essayer
de faire fructifier petit à petit
lamélioration lente de Magnus et c'est
très très bien de faire car
il adore ça c'est des positions qu'ils
préfèrent et
franchement j'ai hâte de voir la suite
de la partie encore une fois Magnus à
chaque partie qui fait c'est une
masterclass et là il a un avantage de
structure du coup on va voir un petit
peu comment comment il va mener ça
c'est bien dit
et en plus regarde même le coup tour des
cartes on voit pas que jouer sur la
structure on va aussi améliorer nos
pièces et restreindre les pièces
adverses
tous les positions
stratégiques se joue beaucoup sur la
structure et l'activité des pièces mais
il faut bien comprendre que les échecs
en général ça se joue à double sens et
qu'il va donc falloir à la fois faire
fructifier nos avantages et aussi
s'occuper de la position adverse et de
restreindre l'adversaire dans ses plans
donc là on va essayer de combiner des
doubles actions et c'est de trouver des
coûts qui sont multifonctions
qui gêne l'adversaire et qui nous
favorise
peut-être E4 un moment et pour l'instant
Magnus a envie d'attendre avant de jouer
c'est pousser contre compromettantes
les pions une fois qu'on bouge le pion
bah c'est terminé c'est jouer du coup on
a le temps il va prendre son temps avant
de le faire bon il pourrait jouer au 4
ici mais vous voyez il va vraiment
prendre son temps dans la partie
améliorer un peu les pièces avant
améliorer un peu le roi améliorer un peu
le cavalier tout ça avant de pousser les
pions trop vite dans la nature on nous
dit qu'un verre est un peu mieux on va
aller voir un peu ce qui se passe enfin
c'est intéressant alors
scène c'est difficile de répondre à
cette question d'ailleurs parce que
normalement c'est sur noir mais je te
dis pas non plus de jouer F4 c'est ça
que là-bas voilà
en fait c'est assez logique de laisser
passer votre coup de casse blanche donc
plutôt sur noir ça c'est la question
basique
mais en même temps faut absolument pas
se faire fixer l'option E3 dont on aura
besoin donc dans certaines positions bon
là il y aura accent peut-être cavalier
C5 qui sera joué et voilà bon ça a été
joué et du coup on a encore la cartouche
E4 donc on peut le faire mais il fallait
pas se faire bloquer la structure donc
pour
les questions blancs et noir il y a la
couleur des fous qui influence là
d'ailleurs le Food E6 s'est fait coincé
sur les cases blanches les pions sont
fixés les pions le pion F5
particulièrement donc le fou des noirs
est bloqué que le fou E2 des blancs qui
a plus de latitude mais il faut aussi
penser au squelette d'option
c'est-à-dire l'option E3 est arriéré
donc il faut pouvoir le pousser parce
que sinon s'il est fixé pour toute la
partie ben on verra jamais notre cas de
contrôle s'exprimer donc il n'y a pas
que la couleur entre guillemets il y a
aussi les autres aspects du jeu
c'est ça et donc après des fois de
position on peut aussi mettre les pions
sur blanc
si on arrive à dominer du coup le fou
adverse
imaginons s'il le faut par exemple il
était en C8 si je pouvais mettre un pion
en F5 tu vois pour voir bloquer
ce fou c'est aussi une possibilité
donc c'est en général sur noir pour
laisser passer votre fou mais des fois
elle peut être aussi donc là à citer un
exemple de restriction on mettrait les
pions très avancés sur blanc pour
bloquer le fouet demi et sera encore
pire pour l'adversaire et il y a enfin
un dernier exemple c'est de pousser sur
blanc pour exploser la chaîne de pions
c'est à dire mettre les cases blanches
en tension en échangeant les pions sur
case blanche pour favoriser notre fou
attention que ça soit pas que ce soit à
notre profit et non pas au profit de
l'adversaire c'est toujours le risque
évidemment
c'est ça donc du coup c'est une position
qui peut clairement améliorer etc du
coup on va on va avoir un peu ce qui va
faire on va voir un peu ce qu'il faut ce
que fait mais elle je te propose
exactement on nous a cité dans le chat
apparemment il aurait un avantage mais
bon c'est un avantage d'ordinateur parce
que là la position est toujours
symétrique
qui passe pas grand chose
c'est l'avantage dû au trait au départ
quoi si vous voulez on a après avec les
Blancs un quart voir un tiers de pion à
peu près quand on démarre là on peut
dire il y a un quart un tiers d'option
quoi
il est un peu mieux mais c'est pas un
truc
c'est facile de toute façon de juger
cette position les rois c'est égal le
matériel c'est égal donc pour se
départager on a plus de la structure et
l'activité la structure est symétrique
donc c'est égal et les pièces de Maxime
sont un tout petit chouïa mieux placé
c'est pour ça que je préfère à la
position de Maxime et c'est pour ça que
l'ordi il va être ça en calculant
évidemment
alors est-ce que là
je pense à un truc mais non c'est pas
bon
c'est pas facile de dire pourquoi l'ordi
il a dit là gros gros plus d'avoir pris
sa décision je pense que Maxime va jouer
tout reprend à 8
pour provoquer d'un point 8
et après je sais pas peut-être cavalier
fin cavalier 3 et peut-être un problème
sur le pion de dessin peut-être dame F3
mais bon c'est dur en tout cas vous
voyez que l'ordinaire un petit peu
ticket attention est plus agréable
l'idée par contre fil rouge
de la position de Maxime avec son
cavaliers 3 cavaliers F4 au début c'est
pressé sur des 5 donc ça a l'air plutôt
de
de bien se passer puis la pression est
plus facile à jouer il a 3 minutes 30
qu'il a bouffé à part Aviane donc c'est
quand même des bonnes nouvelles salut
sissounet
donc le pion des cinq structurellement
c'est pas trop grave qu'on soit bien
d'accord à un moment il pourrait y avoir
ces 7 en 6 mais pour jouer c'est cette
C6 qui viendrait tenir le pions avec les
pions il y a un peu de boulot c'est pas
si facile
un peu en retard
donc décide de faire une menace pour
accélérer un petit peu les choses et et
améliorer ses pièces
c'est vrai que la dame en 8 on n'a pas
forcément envie de la mettre en 8 parce
qu'après il y aura une tour en un mois
donc c'est pas vraiment un abandon de
colonne pour les blancs de jouer cela
après s'il arrive à jouer cavaliers
G6 tout ça ça peut ça peut être très
vite égal mais je trouve vraiment le
moyen qu'on avait décrit quand vous êtes
dominé en termes d'activité de pièces
souvent les échanges peuvent vous
permettre de revenir dans la partie
du monde il y a deux ans je crois et
c'est parti au départage en Armageddon
il me semble d'ailleurs
dans cette Coupe du monde et du coup
du coup c'est comme un très solide
d'aller par avion qui toi les gens ont
mon historique bien sûr historique et
donc bon on va voir
mais le problème c'est qu'il y a dame 1
qui arrivait et chaque qui fait peur
aussi donc là en fait
Maxime il voulait pas entendre parler du
Fou G4 surtout parce que dame 1
peut-être que la dame s'engage dans un
combat qui qui n'est pas le sien mais en
tout cas H5 ce qui est génial c'est
qu'il s'empêche fougère la moins bonne
pièce de l'adversaire c'est le fousset 8
donc vouloir éviter fuj4 c'est tout à
fait légitime et bien sûr là sur fougère
maintenant il a calécarde donc c'est
complètement interdit quand il y a 5
c'est un super coup qui a été trouvé par
Maxime et je pense qu'il va prendre un
avantage conséquent après ce coup-là
et normalement c'est pas un Maxime de
proposer les échanges de pièces ce que
l'on a dit c'est appauvrirait son
avantage sauf que là c'est pas une
proposition d'échange l'adversaire ne
peut pas le prendre comme stouf vient de
nous l'expliquer il y a une tactique
derrière donc c'est hyper malin parce
que visuellement on se dirait à première
vue que les Blancs c'est pas leur jeu de
jeu car il y a 5 sauf qu'en fait c'est
très menaçant c'est un coup piquant
c'est un coup de Grand Maître et
maintenant ça va être très dur pour
pouvoir bien je vous assure
je pense qu'à partir de ce moment-là
Maxime va gagner la partie
alors est-ce que par exemple
cavalier prend d'un point d'amour
je préfère comme ça je garde mon fout
des trois
et on tient bien la boutique ok non
c'est de trouver une astuce
elle a quand même on laisse tout faire
avec ces problèmes
je mets tout
on parle
festival ouais non ok je pensais pouvoir
passer à ce moment-là tu imagines
la totale la totale
qui pourrait arriver ici oui oui là
c'est dangereux le cavalier à chaque
peut amener des motifs tactiques
le dame de stouffe
attendez la caméra qui qui est parti du
jour
pendant quelques secondes
il a perdu du temps on me dit que Van
forest qui perd en 20 coups ça
m'intéresse
où est-il
de la matrice
où es-tu
je ne vois pas
je suis fou en fait
[Musique]
du monde de Bleach justement assez
célèbre où il bat jobava son compatriote
il me semble que c'est lui en ratant
complètement son début d'ouverture bon
la partie était assez normale mais là
c'est un peu gâté
il a fait une sale partie avant de
Forest il est passé complètement à côté
19 coups
non c'est un vrai
[Musique]
on peut vous dire que c'est la classe et
il a gagné le tata style ça veut dire il
a déjà gagné une tata style et du coup
bah là il est passé vraiment à côté du
coup mvl donc il y a eu un joli couple
normal
[Musique]
donc
quoi c'était l'urgence de la position
moi juste passer la dame pour un jour
passer la tour marquez à travers
un petit peu ramener ce cavalier à la
maison
et puis je pense en petit peut-être un
fou F5 tours 8 qui va arriver les blancs
font un peu mieux la structure qui a
changé voyez il est plus symétrique
aussi pour attaquer un peu les deux
pièces
[Musique]
pour le coup mais
j'ai une idée ça va ça va pas te plaire
mais
j'ai essayé de jouer des trucs des fois
pour faire valoir aussi mon caresse
planche j'ai pensé à dommage 400 faut F4
bah c'est la partie ce qui est bien
c'est que Maxime a joué le coup
le coup légitime sur damage 4 je pense
que je vais pas loin de prendre je
pensais
est-ce que tu as le droit de jouer comme
ça
ah oui non moi j'ai oui oui j'ai oublié
là tu fais tout ce que je veux tu
m'ouvres les cases blanches mais ok ça
l'a je jouerai cavalier si c'est chèque
sur ton truc
je suis un peu repris après avoir cédé
une pièce en un coup
tout à fait modeste tout à fait modeste
non mais ok c'était un truc un peu
bizarre
je pense à un truc marrant un peu
tactique oups
je peux manger ici ma structure elle est
pas terrible
intermédiaires vous voyez et s'il bouge
par exemple la dame et ben l'idée c'est
de manger ici et après d'essayer de
masser des trucs sur le roi du style
faut F3 ou attaquer un peu sur l'option
ici et bon il a au moins ça il a même
d'autres choses mais Kevin souligné
aussi le cavalier approche bistro tu
sais ah oui complètement sur un point FC
c'est ben je pourrais manger le foot ou
que ça peut plus protégé et surtout on
prend ben elles sont un peu je fou j'ai
trois les deux hommes sont en prises
mais au final l'instinct noir
c'est fort il y a des pions partout bref
donc du coup bon c'était une proposition
un petit peu
qui a été proposé et la fois F5 a été
joué qui est plus solide qui est plus
normal et après faut que j'ai 5 info F5
et ben on va avoir en échange de fou
sûrement en D6 et un cavalier blanc qui
va
c'est quand même très pénible faut
toujours se méfier des dames B3 aussi à
certains moments une bombe de 2
simplement ok donc il se pressent pas
très bien
pseudo isolé maintenant puisque
isolé c'est un pion tout seul qui a pas
de copains pion il y a éventuellement le
pion F7 qui pourrait venir protéger le
piano 4 c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas
dire que le Pione 4 est isolé en
pratique pour l'instant il est loin de
bouger ce qui est loin de devenir
soutenir le pion 4
alors je pense qu'on va se faire
on va vraiment se faire avoir maxime a
prévu tout droit cavalier G3 ce que ce
cavalier au bord faut bien le recycler
un moment et on va taper là où ça fait
mal
tout à l'heure là le F3 qui pourrait
arriver à un moment avec le vis-à-vis
tour d'âme
le double de temps de l'adversaire donc
bah pression vous voyez donc avoir s'il
arrive à mettre un peu de pression à
gagner la partie on va voir un petit peu
ce que nous fait
Sébastien Mazet dans cette partie
je vais vous mettre le côté noir là je
dois rien dire qu'il avait une belle
partie
le triplement ouais sur la colonne C
fait mal juste voir ce qui s'est passé
dans la partie je vais enregistrer du
matin un tout petit peu en arrière c'est
marrant parce que si vous regardez bien
je guéri il a donné la paire de fou ok
mais il a le pion c'est en échange
c'est-à-dire que le pion c'est faible et
quand on a la position finale en tête
maintenant on sait qu'il a réussi à lui
faire très très mal Sébastien essaie de
de replacer ses pièces et regarder le
plan d'allier je dirais le fil
conducteur de cette partie qui est une
partie de l'école un véritablement c'est
d'agresser le pion c'est et d'échanger
les pièces pour appauvrir le jeu et on
vient agresser le pioncer
magnifique cette partie
regardez la simplicité du jeu blanc ça
fait penser aux parties d'ailleurs de
Carlson certaines fois bien sûr qu'on
aime beaucoup il a fixé Sébastien Mazet
dans les cordes et maintenant il va
commencer à lui taper dessus
alors
moi c'est quoi la rêve de tamine Kevin
profite du moment où tu peux avoir une
crête de queue alors la crête de punk
c'est par rapport à quoi
ce que tu as compris la rêve de Tamines
par rapport à ta coupe je ne sais pas
là j'ai pas justement pour faire la
crête ça va être dur à la mise sous toi
tu pourrais plus facilement faire une
crête demain le truc qui se transforme
complètement tu sais mais moi je vais de
limiter là je viens de chez le coiffeur
je suis je suis coincé quoi
je vous ai fait une petite coupe de Noël
là je pense que vous l'avez vu parce que
souvent vous focalisez sur sur les
vestes là j'ai fait une petite coupe de
Noël et du coup
pas mal
retour à 8 en tout cas j'ai pas compris
la colonne semi-ouvertes et des deux
pions sont faites des grosses faiblesses
dans sa merde là il a franchement on
voit pas l'aider moi on n'a pas trouvé
le plan pour lui et s'il en trouve tant
mieux pour lui non en fait si vous
voulez il se fait il se fait visser quoi
il s'est fait visser ce qu'il adore
faire d'ailleurs Seb mais là je joue un
joueur de de classement mondial
et du coup
c'était par rapport à
c'est moche c'est moche c'est moche
c'est une base attaque ça se voit plus
quand les cheveux sont coupés évidemment
ben oui ben petit à petit on perd ses
cheveux
toi tu as une très très bonne
capillarité non tu vois là encore déjà
là c'est
merci Tamines merci Tamines j'espère pas
les perdre ça c'est un truc
ouais bah de toute façon on sait que
c'est plus ou moins héréditaire ces
choses là donc moi je sais que je suis
coincé petit à petit ça va se dégrader
l'histoire moi aussi c'est mon père mon
père aime ses cheveux à 19 ans
toute la famille et pourquoi chaque fois
que mon frère on se on se vanne pour
savoir qui va aller prendre en premier
j'imagine bien et
j'ai bien aimé Néandertal qui a été très
très bon évidemment
stream sponsorisé par Jean-Louis David
qui a un partenariat avec chasse comme
maintenant tout trouver
pas mal d'endertale facile et en tout
cas Aniche qui en profite qui profite si
vous voulez d'avoir créé un foyer
hypertendu sur l'eldame qui a obligé
Sébastien à mettre ses pièces à la dame
pour maintenant venir créer un second
foyer une seconde faiblesse un second
point d'accroche sur maintenant l'aile
le roi et regardez il transfère ses
pièces que quand vous avez plus d'espace
que votre adversaire en soumission vous
pouvez en profiter pour aller de l'autre
côté et là on est à la au bord de la
rupture des deux côtés mais surtout sur
les rois maintenant extrêmement dur ici
pour
regarder la combinaison je commence à
regarder comme ça mais j'avais pas
trouvé alors Carlier C5 maintenant qui
nous donne la solution qu'est-ce qu'il a
vu
[Rires]
qui finissent un ambiance pour tes
cheveux c'est comme hyper bon quoi c'est
hyper bon et gros dents qui nous dit de
la team petrolane est aux commentaires
on vous fait plaisir et j'espère que
vous êtes attentif aussi au niveau des
commentaires échiquier parce que
tout simplement l'interception et c'est
perdu donc là il faut faire un couple
donc on est là
oups
vous la conseille pour les cours pour
moi
j'ai cliqué sur un mauvais truc
bien marrer c'est typiquement tu le sais
bien ah le cavalier à 5 de part à viande
et dans les cordes
et malgré les petites entourloupes il va
pas réussir à s'entourer rapidement
le cavalier en
direct il y avait cavalier C4 on a coupé
la case de rebond du cavalier ou les
deux cases du rebond en un coup c'est ça
doit être très confortable c'est un pion
de plus déjà il y a dame G4 qui doit
être l'astuce de paraviane donc comment
on va Adam G4 qui permet de ramer
cavalier aussi en C4 voilà peut-être
encore c'est pas sûr quand même comment
on peut faire dans ce que pas juste
donne des quatre
je pense que je te laisse dans ta
chaîne j'avais trouvé quelque chose tous
tes prises 3 et dans ma F2 mais bon ok
tu as le pion tu as une case de sortir
c'est ici le seul hein c'est statique
pour ce Dame des quatre regardez comme
c'est joli conserve les menace c'est sur
Pione F2 roi F2 je pense que ça peut
être le choix de Maxime dans cette
position elle conserve une menace tout
fait un grand sang-froid
F2 de Maxime et une personne de boeuf ça
a fait nul en fait je regarde un petit
peu du coin de l'oeil mais
pas réussi à obtenir donc ça pourtant tu
nous avais promis je trouve quelque
chose qui s'est produit il a obtenu la
finale de pion gagnante qui n'a pas
gagné
pas de bol le contre-exemple tu sais
on a parlé de la pollution juste qu'on
avait un
majorité ici mais malheureusement pas le
roi blanc il a pas d'accès si je pouvais
rentrer avec mon roi ça gagnerait c'est
un contre-exemple évidemment et tout bof
a tenu facilement contre Magnus avec les
pièces noires cette position il doit
être content de lui de bof qui est aussi
un des préparateurs d'ailleurs de de de
47 qui s'était fait d'ailleurs taper sur
les doigts enfin il fait critiquer
d'ailleurs par la Fédération russe pour
avoir aidé Carlson dans le match entre
contre les paumes qui lui aime russe
et puis on prend F2 on reprend F2
regardez là la proposition de souffle
c'est c'est produite jusqu'à la fin et
très très sympa qui va arriver ça va
être ça va être perdu ce qui est beau
c'est l'aspect visuel du roi évidemment
qui ne sommes pas en sécurité mais il
n'y a pas d'échec et maintenant le
cavalier par contre va être perdu et
regardez le luxe de mvl c'est de faire
un petit tour pour en vouloir toujours
plus
et maintenant le petit bécable de faim
et puis abandon prochainement pour David
pallavian
peut-être qu'il va essayer de poser
quelques problèmes
tu joues les coups parce que tu vois
mais sauf que Maxime a quand même cinq
minutes donc malheureusement pour lui et
la révolte des anciens nous dit Charlie
avec victoire de mvl guéri karwana qui
est un peu malheureux c'est qu'on a
parié sauf sur aucun des joueurs cité
mais bon ils sont peut-être déjà
nos joueurs sont encore quand même là il
est où d'ailleurs
par contre moi je suis intéressé par une
partie genre j'aimerais qu'on aille voir
deux secondes
la partie de neiman contre McDo slow qui
je pense qui va va gagner pour pour
Niman Iman qui va gagner cette partie
[Musique]
est-ce que j'ai le droit de jouer un
coup comme F6 pour te fixer
à voir si j'arrive parce que bon je
t'aime tout à deux et après je peux
peut-être jouer 4 j'avais pensé à fond
pour faire une sorte de manger
et puis tu peux m'enfiler aussi avec toi
8 dans le premier dedans prends mes deux
fous B2 et tour B8 donc du coup j'arrive
jamais à donc là il va falloir jouer
avec l'activité de la part de fou
aujourd'hui et revenir un petit peu à
hauteur de 47
tout ça encore on va voir un petit peu
ce qui se passe après la première
journée on pensait que un
match 45 neiman était totalement
impossible vu la
lame complètement là il revient
complètement il est en train d'aller
chercher voilà il va le chercher
pietrogue semble se moquer un peu de la
promotion moi j'aurais dit maxouglu mais
c'est la promotion bretonne donc c'est
pas et souvent je suis pas hyper fort
sur les prononciations de de noms de
joueurs donc je m'y risque pas trop max
[Musique]
c'est facile pour nous et ok allons voir
un petit peu Jules ce que nous fait ce
que nous fait Jules dans ce
présent
et dans ma chambre
ouais mais bon bien sûr vous avez
compris même si c'est des belles
intentions sur le principe
qui gère sans aucun problème le truc toi
aussi enlever sa dame passer en G3
en fait sûrement que c'est mieux pour
les blancs vous voyez d'ailleurs la
jauge c'est très bien mais c'est
vraiment une position qui peut
se compliquer et c'est un bon une bonne
position pour carotte
ça peut être un petit peu chaud mais au
final si je mange là et que j'arrive pas
à trouver du jeu bah je vais risque de
tout perdre avec les avec les avec les
Noirs donc on a un peu inquiet quand
même pour pour juste dans cette position
en tout cas en tout cas que ce soit McDo
slow max doudou pietrogue est ravi de
nos de nos prononciations
alors du coup maxime a gagné ça a été
abandon
[Musique]
qui est mort contre regazzi qui est mon
poulain d'ailleurs dans ce dans ce
projet
du monde je l'ai écrit bien sûr il a un
peu moins quand même cette partie contre
sans doute mais bon il faut travailler
ces positions de techniquement c'est pas
facile
après on peut faire confiance à Kemer le
seul désavantage réel c'est le foie de
Kemer alors est-ce que faut faire foudre
et s'exposer à de 5 ou est-ce qu'il faut
faire des 5 pour échanger le fous voilà
autant de questions qu'il faut se poser
mais en tout cas on sait que c'est
vraiment gagnant maintenant il faut
trouver
un jour à échanger ses pions pas être
pas mal qui joue des cinq tu vois pour
essayer de fixation tout réussis ce cap
ça a l'air d'être très fort
F30 probablement tout réussisse E4 la 6e
le Pione 7 ça fait beaucoup d'avantages
après c'est pas assez simple parce qu'on
regarde si je prends si je prends de F
par an mais il y a déjà très vite pour
ces deux qui va venir attaquer ici à toi
de revenir peut-être que du coup le
mieux moi je dois directement
et
il compte sûrement faire le 4 mais du
coup 4 contre
j'ai une idée là-dessus je prends quand
même de la tour F ouais
légal
[Musique]
non mais tour 1 2 3
et surtout Air France j'ai changé
et ils sont très avancés en plus autant
dire que j'aurais pas
trop quand même pour l'adversaire
c'est intéressant en tout cas à regarder
mais en tout cas c'est sans doute pour
ça qu'il a pas voulu laisser la mer
6 on réactif quand même par rapport à
ton roi passif c'est pas sûr en vrai
[Musique]
mon roi il peut vite
en tout cas donc là il a pas mangé il a
fait directement tours C2
monter le roi donc là il va sûrement y
avoir un petit roi F7
j'y crois pas trop parce que je pensais
qu'il voulait mettre la tour s'activer
la tour ailleurs
ça bloque la Tour Eiffel son idée
maintenant ce qu'il veut que les pièces
là sont un peu inactifs et peut-être
demain
une possibilité pour essayer de
s'activer F4 de jouer F4 et je pourrais
F2 et je sors de l'étau et c'est bon
après c'est pas mal mais il va le faire
et ma tour elle est rangé mon Roi peut
pas tu vois la tour bouge pas à cause du
plan de recettes
et
un F4 c'est un très très bon coup et
c'est le coup qui va gagner la partie
je pense qu'après ça va être quasiment
terminé je vois pas trop comment il peut
s'en sortir je sais plus où j'ai joué
qui est mère dans un pronostic oui
j'essaie de te faire croire mais pas du
tout non
[Rires]
j'aurais bien aimé j'aurais bien aimé
[Musique]
en fait si vous voulez j'ai fait des
réglages hier avec avec l'invité qu'on a
eu puis là on a un nouvel invité c'est
Kevin moi j'étais là hier Kevin non il
est possible que du coup les micros soit
un petit peu différents dites moi si on
m'entend peut-être pas assez par rapport
à Kevin ou si c'est l'inverse
éventuellement je peux je peux te faire
plaisir
que tu sois au top non mais c'est même
pas ça mais en fait si tu veux chaque
réglage
tu sais à quel point je trouve ça
terrible
ah mais voilà si jamais il y a un truc
de micro dites-nous bien sûr parce que
des fois c'est un pack globalement nous
dit qu'il a pu
plus fort et pas d'échec évidemment papa
d'échec sinon ce serait bah non mais je
vois que dans merci souvent souvent on
nous dit ça j'ai au moins un micro très
fort
je viens de baisser Kevin il a dit
perdre son point hello dites moi si
ça va mieux là il faut que tu parles
Kevin j'ai essayé de vraiment de tout
vous dire sur cette finale qui va être
gagné pas Vincent quemer sans aucun
souci puis après
par contre attention il faut pas il faut
pas changer les pions parce que trois
contre deux ça peut faire nul ça défend
ça dépend des très bonne de Cyril qui
nous dit kevin est plus haut sur sur
l'image que stouffe attention ça va se
régler ça et d'ailleurs ça c'est moi qui
contrôle je peux te baisser
et au niveau du on l'entend plus Kevin
et tiens qui propose qu'on me mute malin
je peux te apparemment c'est mieux dites
nous un pas de blague sur ce qu'on
entend plus Kevin ou pas parce que là du
coup on est vraiment en train d'essayer
de régler des trucs
[Musique]
maintenant c'est pas une blague
écoutez on va remonter un petit peu
alors là on va tuer
par rapport
à mes paroles donc dès que je suis un
peu plus bas souffre c'est dur pour lui
quoi ouais donc maintenant qui est venu
normalement il doit être au moins mon
niveau je pense que maintenant je la
ramasse parfait là c'est parfait
maintenant c'est bon je voulais dire
kevin est maintenant moins fort que ça
est très bon ça promet pour le karaoké
de fin de stream bien joué d'ailleurs
Darty
tu arrives à mon niveau Kevin parfait du
top du bon là techniquement stouf et
en fait c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'en
fait hier on avait on avait notre invité
et du coup n'hésitez pas à nous dire si
jamais il y a des trucs comme ça nous on
s'entend pas donc
n'hésitez pas en tout cas on fait tout
pour que stream soit soit de bonne
qualité et soit
et soit sur les parties on peut rien
faire
si les joueurs décident de bien jouer on
préfère on a pas la main c'est ça
[Musique]
qui serait trop vert
mais comme je suis pas chez moi
ça dépend aussi la luminosité évidemment
et du coup j'ai pas mes lumières machin
[Musique]
j'ai pris une petite lampe portable et
puis comme ça fait le taf non mais c'est
très bien très bien mais demain tu seras
peut-être au moins auxiliaire que moi
on voit la petite lumière
c'est le soleil du Finistère évidemment
Néandertal très perspicace
pour la fin du stream avec stouf à la
baguette au platine
alors il a fait nul contre fedoce
vient de gagner aussi
donc ça me va très bien
[Musique]
est-ce qu'elle te va très bien
parce que là
cette finale de tourne me paraît pas
très saine c'est compliqué sans que on
va pouvoir changer de partie si vous
voulez on peut aller on peut aller sur
un petit
je vais voir ce que j'ai en caméra déjà
parce qu'en caméra j'ai quoi la salut
ah mais je vous ai pas mis la caméra
j'aurais pu vous mettre la caméra quand
même je suis quand même pas très sympa
ce qui est bien c'est que gros gros dent
a modéré le chat en disant ça y est
fatigue générale du chat ça parle moins
cher
salut makroll
bravo
la classe là vous avez les deux joints
à gauche avec les Blancs
contre contre irigazie voilà deux des
stars montantes des échecs mondiaux
ouais c'est le c'est le futur les deux
joueurs qui ont 2700 passés et qui ont
qui sont à peine majeurs
en tout cas les gaz il est majeur et qui
marche je suis pas sûr
et l'option h va être pris un
prochainement
en force
est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir une
autre partie ouais c'est un gars en
force là je crois donc on a pas besoin
de rester effectivement ouais c'est
terminé le pion il tombe moi la dernière
fois qu'on a quitté une partie comme ça
c'est on a on est revenu c'était c'est
une autre histoire
à 18 ans OK
en micro je sais pas combien il a Kévin
mais aux échecs il a peut-être 46 en
tout cas c'est que
c'est exact
et alors attends je vais on va revenir
sur la cam normal du coup c'est terminé
la finale on voit que là ça prend l'eau
et c'est perdu on va partir à la maison
qui a les blancs ici bah c'est pas clair
du tout tu vois que le pion noir c'est
chaud avant c'est que c'est pas clair du
tout que se passe-t-il sur apprendre
ah ça a fait nul en fait ça a répété la
position
ça fait nul
et ça a répété
casse blanche c'est très très compliqué
cette ce type de produit
les pièces et faire une faute de
ok je pense bon ça fait nul OK
et ce que d'autres parties à voir donc
il y avait Nakamura qui joue encore qui
joue contre contre
[Musique]
pas gagner ici
il y a eu tout rage 7 d'ailleurs on voit
la caméra
qui vient de faire ça il va manger la
tour
mais quand même pas mal le petit bonama
avec les Noirs
super résultats quand même et merci on a
parlé hier de lui qui a à peine 16 ans
et
donc même génération un peu que Google
tout ça qui a quasiment 2600 hello déjà
en partie lente et aussi en blitz qui va
te faire annuler contre Nakamura grosse
perte
à s'envoler un autre endroit qui qui
réserves pour mon pari je t'assure
Moussard qui est noir ici et qui se bat
pour pour éventuellement faire nul ici
pas facile hein
mais les pions paraissent très très
avancés
maintenant
c'est ça alors il essaie il essaie quand
même légitimement de pousser son pion h
pour trouver un contre jeu
ça paraît vraiment le coup professionnel
le coût du professionnel exactement ce
que on se reconnaît bien tous les deux
moi je suis pas professionnel c'est que
moi techniquement je suis pas le
meilleur mais moi non plus pour autant
c'était tellement logique de jouer tout
achète et travailler après
devant exactement travailler encore donc
c'est important très important quand
vous jouez d'essayer de de
t'empêcher ton avancer comme ça empêcher
le contre jeu adverse c'est important
donc tourage c'est à 3 V6
[Musique]
très bien joué de la part de
l'adversaire et si Jules venais à perdre
cette position là je pense que
ça serait la déprime pour cette journée
un sur trois ouais ce n'est pas
suffisant pour jouer les premiers rôles
donc ça ça serait dur à avaler donc là
on va voir 3 et peut-être du coup
derrière une petite c'est terminé
Jules qui qui fait pas une deuxième
bonne fin une bonne deuxième journée
après le tournoi est fort encore une
fois bien sûr bien sûr c'est 2006 à
chaque rendre et là on voit la caméra on
voit
à droite c'est Amman hamberton de
chessbra qui joue ici on peut aller voir
après sa partie un peu
j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur sur ça sur
Youtube pour ceux qui veulent aller voir
sur ma chaîne youtube j'ai fait une
vidéo où j'ai fait un match en fait
pendant une heure plus d'une heure faire
un match contre contre lui sur chescom
et du coup je l'ai posté
je le vois pas est-ce que tu avais bien
fidélisé ou pas il m'a battu au final
mais ça a été en fait j'ai perdu deux
trois filets derrière à la fin et au
final je perds de quoi égal pendant
longtemps
et à mon hamleton qui est quand même
très fort en genre de Blitz qui a très
souvent 2008
en difficulté là aujourd'hui l'un des
difficultés avec avec un changement
avec son cavalier
c'est pas simple voir si le roi noir est
le roi blanc reste de passer parce que
H4 pourra aussi un jour être joué option
pour le cas réellement plus les pions
s'échangent plus c'est c'est simple on
va dire entre guillemets pour
de nulle pour les noirs
blancs et après rechasser le roi avec
cavalière cavalier
pas
que les joueurs ont fait la veille
mais il y en a qui sont très sérieux
je sais que Jules est très sérieux et
c'est d'ailleurs quand on voit sa
Courbet l'eau
on peut se dire que il a vraiment
il a vraiment
mis toutes les chances de son côté pour
pour progresser mais après là sur un
tournoi comme ça qui n'est pas un trou
noir de partie lente etc on n'est pas
derrière les joueurs le soir pour savoir
ce qu'ils font mais je pense que la
plupart à Bordeaux ça en pro et bien sûr
après il y a forcément des joueurs qui
ont un peu raté leur première journée
non pas les mêmes ambitions que d'autres
et du coup certains sont évidemment
moins sérieux
ça travaille ça peut jouer encore
longtemps cette partie là
qui reste mais il y a pas vraiment de